[Musique]
tu as vu ce qui se passe à toulouse
au nom de quoi tu me parles tu rigoles
ou quoi la radio ou à la télé les
journaux tout le monde en face à le truc
mais oui ce matin chez lo presti
m'attend mais tout moment pas à l'autre
c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu 3 comment
il allait à fond tu aurais parlé aussi
bio c'est en parlant lui aussi lourd
passif et leurs bornes ça veut dire que
tout le monde amis lucion du soir bien
vu sur le plateau de tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tous n'ont en pas
vous connaissez carré olivier les voici
[Applaudissements]
galeo
oh non non non non ces droits c'est pas
vous étiez où la semaine dernière à
l'aquagym à la coiffe et l aquagym sont
pas là vous avez raté un truc un nouveau
truc dans l'émission
je demande
je vous demande de vous et je me demande
de vous arrêter bien alors mise à part
kad et olivier nous recevrons ce soir
patrick sébastien
le team de kuro
bled
mais sa demande
[Applaudissements]
l'accord
à michel houellebecq
et christophe hogard de l'équipe de cale
m
je vous demande de vous j'en étais bon
alors dans quelques instants on sera en
duplex avec londres en interview à
mohamed al fayed qui est le père de dodi
al fayed le fiancé de lady di qui a
trouvé la mort comme vous le savez le 30
août 1997 sous le pont de l'alma et
mohamed al fayed donc le père de dodi al
fayed lui ne crois pas du tout que ce
soit un accident et crois pas du tout
que ce soit le le chauffeur qui était
souhaité tout ça et lui dit qu'un
complot pour assassiner son fils et sa
future belle fille voilà donc on va
discuter avec lui il va nous apporter
les preuves de sa thèse voilà je pense
qu'on dira pas grand chose à ce moment
là non on va l'écouter lui on écoutera
c'est rare qu'il fasse de la télé
surtout en france aussi qui est une
tradition dans cette émission
avant de commencer l'émission on regarde
ce qui s'est passé mieux la semaine
précédente
mal et aux taxis 3 c'est déjà écrit dans
la tête de l'udc ouais c'est tranquille
c'est un bon boulot maintenant je crois
que ça roule quoi faut pas tomber dans
le ridicule et puis jean luc besson
c'est un mec l'aja l'intelligence vraie
attaque si les extraterrestres
on se fait serrer par les keufs comme on
dit on devient vite un arabe tout de
suite tout de suite ah ouais tu te
donnerai plus samy naceri alors là je
sais qu'on trouve avec les entraves aux
pieds les mains notamment dans la cage
sans chaussettes
et puis quand tu es dans le car est
content mène à l'hôpital pour voir si
t'as rien n'était pas malade tu as une
bonne ronde jette sur la gueule et puis
on dit sale [ __ ] ben voila moi je
suis habillée par la redoute mais je
suis tranquille dans les commissariats
la chose qui vous plaît le plus dans le
sexe flirter ouais ouais
qu'est ce qui vous plaît le mois les
trucs apache et rascom savait pas cher
on a écouté sa vie je parle ne seront
jamais d'aaland surtout les gars vous
faites vos affaires entre fait nos
affaires
exactement le genre de comportement que
j'ai envie que mon film déclenché cela
j'ai envie qu'on sorte des salles avec
des enfants alors ce qu'on voit dans
votre film qui s'en foutent
est ce que vous êtes fait souvent fourré
vous fairy québécois quand on fait cette
carrière
est ce que vous aimez turluter dans
votre salle de bain c'est rare que je
tire au but mais j'aimerais pouvoir le
faire vous et vous sur l'ut et non pas
encore est ce qu'il y ait une traduction
française qui est drôle de tour l'été
ici alors d'une pipe ça se saurait
vous les faites en effet julie
extraordinaire pour une fois je vois
comme ça quand vous avez votre col de
veste et tout sens dessus dessous là
mais c'est la première fois vous avez
jamais fumé de pétards s'est jamais tapé
deux garçons faisaient jamais utiliser
de godemichés nom faisait beaucoup de
choses à apprendre encore je vais vous
dire notre éducation est resté avec nous
on fait une teuf après
si vous étiez une arme un clitoris est
ce que ses larmes quand même qu'ils lame
secrète au plus il fait la loi sur la
terre suivait une arme parce que quand
on peu pressé sur la détente
faire pipi c'est vrai oui
allez-y c'est une émission libre ici je
vis à vis a pas de problème à les faire
pipi et les bras comme ça on sera tous
combien de temps j'allais bien que
c'était pas mal c'était tout le monde en
a parlé
le best-of de la semaine dernière n'ont
rien vu venir
je vous dis
et leurs yeux ont vu que toi pour ricky
montage du livre bah ouais je vis
depardieu extraordinaire là on va donc
on va discuter avec mohamed al fayed
souvient intervenir pouvait intervenir
il n'y a pas de bien alors monsieur al
fayed
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté de
répondre aux questions de tout le monde
en parle
vous êtes en campagne de john mcnamara
qui est votre directeur de la sécurité
mais avant de converser avec vous
d'abord un rappel des faits donc sur
cette affaire un jugement a été rendu en
septembre 1999 qui a conclu à un
accident de voiture dû à l'alcoolémie du
chauffeur de la mercedes
henri-paul depuis le début vous monsieur
al fayed vous n'y croyez pas et vous
parler de complot de meurtre organisé
par la couronne britannique aidée par
les services secrets anglais américains
et français
et quel serait le mobile de ce crime ou
de ces crimes
le mobile de ce crime
c'est un racisme absolue
la famille royale et l'establishment
dans ce pays créé le racisme partout
dans le monde et la personne qui
n'acceptera jamais mon fils qu en tant
qu'egyptien parce qu'il faut bien voir
que il s'agissait du loret s'agit du
beau père du futur roi d'angleterre et
c'est ça la raison
c'est ça le mobile et la personne qui a
organisé qui organisait cela et qui a
payé de sa poche c'est le prince philip
lorsqu'il était enfant il a passé
beaucoup de temps en allemagne il y
avait un mariage avec deux généraux
d'hitler dans cette famille ça suffit
comme explication les sept personnes a
grandi dans un environnement nazis par
conséquent vous voyez que un mariage
or et étaient compromettants personne ne
sait vraiment pourquoi et comment cela
s'est passé mais monsieur al fayed dans
le pays en angleterre la presse vous
appelle par exemple l'égyptien où le
chèque d'arabie bien que vous soyez la
14e fortune du pays
vous êtes victime d'un certain racisme
mais il y avait aussi la la lutte de
diana contre la cour d'angleterre
elle avait déclaré que charles le roi
d'angleterre le futur roi d'angleterre
était incapable de gouverner et c'est
vrai que sur fond de crise monarchique
en angleterre c'était un problème
d'ailleurs james hewitt qui a été
l'amant de lady di a fait état de
menaces reçues par la princesse diana et
on peut dire qu'il a il a rien à gagner
à révéler sa lui en tous les cas il ya
étaient exactes oui c'est vrai on l'a vu
du reste dans d'autres programmes ou
dans d'autres interviews à la télévision
c'est exactement comme ça que ça s'est
passé personne ne pouvaient approcher
rihanna
cette femme a souffert pendant toute sa
vie de femme mariée elle a souffert
auprès du prince charles le prince
charles ne lui a apporté aucun amour
aucune vie de famille ne lui a apporté
aucune attention à la vivait une vie
tout à fait atroce
elle elle vivait dans un cadre trop
étriqué trop formelle pour elle monsieur
le feuillet en attendaient impatiemment
on attendait impatiemment le livre du
seul rescapé de l'accident c'est le
garde du corps
trevor rhys jones effectivement ils
avaient été rendues amnésiques par
l'accident
maintenant il a retrouvé la mémoire mais
malheureusement il se souvient plus des
dix minutes qui précèdent le drame du
pont de l'alma il se souvient même plus
de l'itinéraire en revanche vous
démontrer qu'il ment dans son livre au
sujet de la bague offerte par votre fils
dodi al fayed à la princesse diana et
ceux ci confirment notre opinion
le garde du corps très fort hills jones
a été retourné par départ des espions
das reich c'est tout à fait vrai la
javel oeil sur cette personne pendant
quatre mois sans moi il ne serait pas
vivant aujourd'hui il a travaillé pour
moi pendant cinq ans je lui faisais
confiance en tant que garde du corps et
il m'a quitté soudainement avec deux
autres gardes du corps donc trois gardes
du corps mon quitter du jour au
lendemain
dans le cadre de relations humaines
normales ça ne se ferait pas ignorer il
y aurait au moins une certaine gratitude
donc sans aucune raison ça s'est passé
comme ça du jour au lendemain on a
craint qu'il retrouve la mémoire
on sait très bien que henri paul qui
travaille pour le service c'est secret
bri et qu'il ya travaillé pendant trois
ans a servi le mi6 parce que tout ça
c'est très délicat toutes ces
informations là donc vous voyez on peut
retourner les gens c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé bien monsieur al fayed vous
dit le jour de l'accident le 30 août
votre fils dodi vous a annoncé ses
fiançailles avec la princesse diana et
ça aurait été officialisée le 1er
septembre de la même année
trevor il jones lui nie complètement il
dit c'est pas vrai ça n'a été qu'une
romance d'été c'est ce qu'on lui a dit
de dire croyez vous que mon fils
discutera de ses relations avec la
presse indienne avec un garde du corps
on peut évidemment faire toutes les
suppositions ou toutes les hypothèses
que l'on veut ayvaz text based moi j'ai
eu des rapports avec les médias
le daily telegraph et autres ya des
centaines d'articles qui porterait la
folie
personne ne peut connaître les faits
personne ne peut savoir ce qui s'est
passé directement c'est mon fils moi
j'ai perdu mon fils et c'était un
complot monsieur le faillite maintenant
on en arrive à un point très précis
trevor rhys-jones donc le garde du corps
dit a dit dans son livre que dodi al
fayed votre fils n'avait jamais acheté
de bagues pour la princesse diana
or vous sur injonction d'un tribunal
britannique vous avez obtenu une requête
auprès du joaillier qui s'appelle
alberto repossi place vendôme et le
joaillier a produit non seulement une
facture de la bague daté du 30 août 1997
mais en plus une vidéo où l'on voit
votre fils dodi al fayed qui entre dans
le
magasin il il ya beaucoup de conneries à
des mensonges
il ya des tissu de conneries les jeux
les services secrets ont fait dire des
tas de choses à tout le monde et je
voudrais que monsieur mcnamara vous
explique un petit peu les détails parce
que lui était responsable à l'époque et
vous donner les détails de ce qui s'est
passé exactement à propos de la bague et
avec alberto repossi on les écoute
monsieur jacques lamarre a good evening
sa permettront d'expliquer que tout ce
qu'a dit très mauricio dans son livre a
fait l'objet de manipulation visant à
prouver qu'il n'y avait pas de
fiançailles
eh bien il faut bien savoir que très bon
risque d'user n'a pas vu rentrer n'a pas
vu de 10 ou diana rentrer dans le bijou
tri la veille de l'accident fatal
la réalité c'est qu'ils sont allés faire
du lèche vitrine dans la vitrine du
joaillier alberto repossi ils ont vu une
magnifique bague
c'était à monaco en réalité ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là c'est que la bague
a été envoyé à paris de dial al fayed a
récupéré la bague auprès de alberto
repossi sur la place vendôme le 30 août
dans la soirée et très boris johnson
aurait accompagné de dial fayed chez le
joaillier pour récupérer la bac mais le
livre est une manipulation les faits
sont travers distordue pour démontrer
que la bague mais asseyez ce que je veux
dire au revoir on comprend très bien
monsieur mcnamara on va passer
maintenant à d'autres points obscurs du
dossier sur lesquels je vous demanderais
d'intervenir très brièvement pour
l'épauler précisé alors les autres
points obscurs du dossier il ya d'abord
la kz lors de l'accident du fils de
monsieur al fayed de dial fayed lui il
est mort sur le coup dans l'accident
mais la princesse diana était encore
vivante après le choc
elle avait une hémorragie interne
personnes la diagnostiquer et on a mis
100 minutes pour l'amener à l'hôpital
est-ce que vous pensez que il ya eu de
la part des urgentistes qui s'en sont
occupés soit une faute involontaire soit
une faute
en terre mais oui il ya une erreur mais
délibéré il fallait il a fallu une heure
une heure quinze pour les de finale de
l'allemagne jusqu'à l'hôpital c'est
impensable c'est évident qu'il voulait
se débarrasser d'aller de 2,10 pourquoi
ont-ils immédiatement dit que henri paul
était ivre au volant
il était le professeur lacan ci qui
était donc le médecin en charge le sens
de henri paul n'était pas le sens de
horse ball c'était le sens de quelqu'un
d'autre parce qu'il y avait quinze
cadavres à la morgue ce soir là et je
suis certain que l'analyse sanguine
repose sur le sens de quelqu'un d'autre
oui justement monsieur le feu y en a
trouvé dans le dans le corps de
henri-paul le chauffeur de la mercedes
30% de monoxyde de carbone
avec une telle dose de monoxyde de
carbone nous faisons quelqu'un peut pas
marcher
alors on s'est demandé d'où venait ce
monoxyde de carbone
les analyses de contre expertises ont
été refusées pendant 48 heures on se
demande aujourd'hui si le monoxyde de
carbone n'était pas contenue dans les
air bags de la mercedes est ce que vous
croyez à ça c'est très simple notre
expert au royaume uni un autre expert à
lausanne en suisse ont démontré que ce
niveau de monoxyde de carbone n'aurait
pas pu se trouver dans le sens de henri
paul notamment lorsqu'il devait être
vivre c'est vrai vous avez raison il
n'aurait pas pu marcher ni même conduire
évidemment l'explication qui a étonné
par les médecins français toxicologue et
le resort lacombe sait que le monoxyde
de carbone on aurait pu aurait
certainement pu venir des airbags et que
henri paul lors est inhalée mais étant
donné qu'il était mort sur le coup il
n'a pas eu le temps de respirer
les mercedes-benz nous ont dit que les
airbags ne contiennent pas de monoxyde
de carbone aucun expert pathologiste
français ne peut expliquer la présence
du monoxyde de carbone dans le sang dans
ripol c'est impossible ce n'était pas
son sens et aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
la possibilité d'examiner de faire des
analyses qui sont toujours détenus par
les français nés français refuse
catégoriquement de laisser nos experts
indépendants accéder aux échantillons
pour faire des essais indépendants
merci alors autre point obscur du
dossier c'est la façon dont on a
travaillé la police française
l'enquète n'a pas été menée d'après-vous
très correctement
d'abord le lieu de l'accident n'a pas
été préservé par la police ensuite il ya
une fiat uno blanche qui a été vu par
cette témoin qui n'a pas été
véritablement recherché et on n'a jamais
parlé non plus de la moto suiveuse qui
aurait fait une queue de poisson fonds
n'a jamais bien cherché cette moto
suiveuse qui aurait fait une queue de
poisson à la mercedes conduite par henri
paul
alors est-ce que sur le lounge blanche
par exemple est-ce que vous de votre
côté vous avez des informations à cet
égard il y avait eu neuf et une eau dont
le propriétaire était un vietnamien
cette voiture a été testé par la police
française des échantillons de la
peinture de la fiat ont été mis en
correspondance avec la peinture que l'on
a retrouvée sur le mercedes cette
voiture comporte et à un chien à
l'arrière ça a été confirmé ça et ça a
été confirmé par les témoins de l'époque
il y à des examens qui confirme que
cette voiture correspond bien à celle
ayant participé à la collision cependant
on s'en est arrêtée là la police et les
magistrats responsables de leur enquête
se sont arrêtés là alors que à mon avis
la voiture a été trouvé mais on a arrêté
là bien alors il ya deux points qui
militent effectivement pour la théorie
de monsieur al fayed c'est d'abord
effectivement la bague puisque cette
bague à bien
acheter c'est une bague dis moi oui qui
a bien été acheté chez alberto repossi
part de dial fayed pour ses fiançailles
avec la princesse diana
il ya une autre information qui vous a
été transmis ce monsieur al fayed très
récemment par votre avocat parisien un
juge français a fait une requête auprès
des ambassades américaines et anglaises
car on pense que le numéro 2 des
services secrets mi6 était présent à
paris dans la nuit du 30 août 1997
das reich c'est juste c'est exact
c'était en effet le numéro deux du mi6
que ferait le numéro deux du mi6 a à
paris on se le demande rim richartz
pieman et il y avait un autre nom
nicholas langham tous deux étaient à
paris pourquoi se sont ils rendus à
paris trois semaines avant la tragédie
personne ne sait est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas en train finalement de mener toute
cette opération
d'abord parce que c'est tout à fait
naturel mais aussi parce que en tant que
propriétaire du ritz
vous êtes l'employeur de henri-paul le
chauffeur est donc la couronne
britannique où la famille spencer la
famille de lady di peut se retourner
contre vous pour vous attaquer c'est ça
la vie peuvent pas m'attaquer
j'ai accès aux preuves les preuves
existent
j'espère que la cour d'appel se rendra
bien compte de la situation sans les
services secrets français
les services secrets britanniques
n'auraient jamais perpétré ce meurtre
j'espère que la cour d'appel fera la
justice parce que la france est un grand
pays moi j'ai beaucoup investi j'aime la
france et j'ai un domicile en france
donc je n'accepte pas cette situation et
j'espère véritablement que la cour
d'appel rendra justice de moi et moi je
suis père
un père en deuil et je suis un individu
qui aiment la france
j'emploie un grand nombre de personnes
en france et je ne veux pas être traité
en france
comme j'ai été traité dans ce pays
monsieur al fayed dernière question on
vous reproche de faire tout ça aussi par
vengeance contre la famille d'angleterre
parce que vous êtes la 14e fortune du
pays en grande bretagne et vous arrivez
pas à obtenir la nationalité britannique
des synonymes poteau mais c'est pas
important ça pour moi c'est simple
formalité
non je veux pas me venger je n'ai pas
d'esprit de vengeance
je suis un père endeuillé par le décès
de son fils tout père qui aime son fils
ferait exactement la même chose que moi
j'ai la certitude que mon fils a été
assassiné avec la princesse diana et les
services secrets français ont participé
à ce crime
et ils sont les criminels principaux
ayant contribué à aider les services
secrets britanniques et j'espère que les
français attendront bien cela parce que
cela pourrait bien se reproduire ça peut
toucher quelqu'un d'autre qui vit en
france
s'il ne faut pas accepter cela merci
beaucoup de mamans donnent la
possibilité explique avéré sur la
disparition de mon fils est la princesse
diana merci de nous accorder cette
interview en exclusivité merci beaucoup
monsieur al-fayed
merci monsieur jacques lamarre bien
entendu les affirmations de monsieur al
fayed concernant le passé de la famille
royale d'angleterre que la faire
elle-même le constituent que sa propre
version des faits à ce jour même si des
interrogations subsistent aucun rapport
officiel ou expertise sérieux n'est venu
les confirmés la cour d'appel se
prononcera définitivement dans deux mois
sur les causes de l'accident
bien on continue vous l'avez connu
imitateur vous l'avez connu animateurs
le voici réalisateur et acteur voici
patrick sébastien
ah ah
20e bon soir à bagdad al qods est alors
vient de vivre un moment un petit peu un
petit peu grave c'est un petit peu les
révélations de mohamed al-fayed au sujet
de la mort de la princesse diana et son
fils dodi al fayed façon vous les
accidents de mercedes ça vous connaissez
ni stars
un jour vous êtes un jeu vous êtes du
côté de vierzon et vous écouté une
cassette et à un moment on sait pas
pourquoi la radio passe par dessus la
cassette et vous entendez une voix
c'était peut-être radio vierzon tu sais
ça radio vient en vous dit faraj on dit
attention et des orages et dix minutes
plus tard aquaplaning vous vous plantez
en mercedes mais j'ai fait un beau vol
plané j'ai eu un très bon souvenir de ça
parce que j'aurai normalement je dois
crever quoi s'était arrêté à quatre
mètres en mer s'achever 100000 bornes
par an donc il faut que ça arrive
j'étais sur le bord du fossé j'avais la
gueule éclaté je suis ouvert j'ai encore
la cicatrice ici j'étais cassé de
partout je saignais il ya un mec qui
s'est arrêté qui m'a fait [ __ ] patrick
sébastien à merde j'ai pas mon appareil
photo c'est bien ça fait toujours
plaisir
c'est une autre histoire de voiture avec
sébastien qui est assez extraordinaire
c'est que chaque fois que vous mettez
enfin vous avez arrêté mais ça va vous
mettiez un morceau d'edith piaf assez
intéressant que c'est une malédiction
malédiction de piaf mais je suis pas le
seul
we are all qu'est le meneur de jeu
d'europe 1 vous a dit tu sais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous ont appelé
chaque fois qu'il met piaf dans la
voiture c'est pas tellement ça c'est au
tour de pierre fia une il ya une ya une
malédiction au début j'ai pris en
rigolant ouais j'ai un jour je partis en
bagnole et puis je cassette de piaf
j'écoute depuis je me sens trois radars
je trouve pas le gala enfin que des
moeurs mais je veux pas de relation de
cause à effet et puis jetée que sardou à
l'époque et on rentre de gala un soir
j'écoute piaf j'enlève la casse elle
jamais la radio je retombe sur piaf à la
radio je me prend un shoot un feu rouge
explose
je prends un carton bon sens l'hôpital
une semaine après j puis dans ma tête me
dis-je pas trop superstitieux mais je me
dis bon ça fait deux fois que j'ai
désormais envie et je jette la casse est
jaloux par la fenêtre puis je m'arrête à
une station service médical je suis trop
con je reprends ma cassette et jeu et je
fais 100 m j'ai les deux pneus qui
explosent mais alors depuis tu vois je
et j'ai parlé de ça un jour à la radio
et bizarrement il ya plein de gens qui
ont appelé pour me dire il ya une vraie
malédiction j'en ai parlé à jacques
martin qui me disait à l' empire dans la
salle
il ya un truc une loge des quelqu'un
veut imiter piaf il y avait un projet
autres tombes et la fille se casser la
jambe
j'en ai parlé à brialy aussi qui m'a dit
que chaque fois qu'il a voulu montrer la
robe de piaf à quelqu'un à ce moment là
on lui a annoncé un décès c'est quelque
chose qui à elle a eu un destin quand
même qui a qui a tiré un petit peu tout
ça il ya eu et puis quand ils ont voulu
tourner le film de loges
le film n'a pas marché de verre s'est
suicidé je veux dire j'ai eu et j'ai eu
des choses encore plus j'ai le gachon et
terrorisés j'ai eu des choses encore
plus pas grave si tu veux qu'ils m'ont
touchée c'est là que j'ai vécu avec
cette malédiction en permanence et puis
le jour mon fils s'est tué en moto
j'ai pas voulu aller à la morgue le
reconnaître j'ai dit aux flics qui était
là il m'appelle au téléphone qui mieux
mieux reconnaître le corps j attendais
je peux je peux pas bouger rien et j'ai
dit débat décrivait le décrivez moi
puisqu'on n'était pas sûr que ce soit
lui
et le mec il libère et il a un blouson
de cuir avec un aigle sur le dos j'ai
revu la chanson hymne à réciter la
chanson entre et depuis je suis mais je
suis pas le seul à j'avais parlé à des
pousses aussi il se trouvait quand elle
faisait un repas avec plein de monde
dans l'année il y avait un mec qui
disparaissait alors je sais pas d'où ça
vient c'est peut-être que ce personnage
aussi bien cette voix qui pas plus
exceptionnel qu'une autre il y avait
quelque chose de bizarre qui passent
elles étaient toujours habillés en noir
alors c'est peut-être une superstition
bizarre mais maintenant je fais gaffe
comment vous faire gaffe peut-être
peut-être que les didier était en train
d'écouter puis à deux vitesses ce qui
est bizarre c'est que vous croyez à ces
petites choses de superstition et vous
croyez pas en dieu parce qu'en général
quand même ce qui ce oui c'est ça non je
crois pas que je crois l'homme
c'est à dire que je suis je suis un
humaniste c'est à dire que je crois que
toi c'est moi et lui c'est moi lui c'est
moi je crois que je crois qu'on a le
même moteur monté sur des carrosseries
différentes way et c'est pour ça que je
suis humaniste il ya que j'aime les gens
et que je base ma philosophie de vie sur
l'amour vous n'êtes jamais été tentée de
croire même dans les moments les plus
difficiles de votre vie vous jamais dit
moi oh bah non parce qu'ils vont arriver
avant ouais et puis non je veux dire le
côté je vais croire en dieu parce que je
vais mourir attention enfin là oh oui ça
fait un peu la sueur en scandant serait
tellement ça et je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose mais c'est la religion
dieu est amour et puis au nom de ça il
ya une religion contre une autre que tu
as eu le nombre de morts que ça fait
c'est le papa une belle robe
je suis ok sociaux on va passer quand je
disais en vous présentant quand vous
avez connu l'imitateur animateurs matin
vous êtes réalisateur vous êtes acteur
dans un film qui s'appelle thème qui
sort le 26 avril c'est bien ça le
souvenir c'est bien alors mais cette
fois ci la dernière fois qu'il est venu
il a baissé j'avais les cheveux
seydou du salon alors donc avec vous
dans ce film myriam boyer
jean françois balmer bon acteur annie
girardot michel duchaussoy et deux
enfants elle un extraordinaire samuel
duplaix tu l'as vu tout le film et ouais
j'ai vu le film et puis j'ai revu samuel
dupuis dans le film d'alexandre jardin
il a vraiment une gueule c'est vrai que
c'est long mais tout de suite alors je
vais raconter l'histoire le trop bas
sinon mais je raconte le thème du film
évidemment elles montrent pas la fin tu
m alors après avoir vu sa soeur qui est
un peu sado maso sa soeur petit peu un
petit peu quand elle se fait prendre
sauvagement dans une cave gars et je te
raconterai après je précise quand même
que dans tout le film je me suis
appliqué à skis et il se passe un mois
qui n'a pas un sens ya pas une fin c'est
même pas un baiser sur canal c'est vrai
que là c'est même cette scène là est
assez tourné d'une façon assez prude
violent alors donc le simple et du
village il voit sa soeur qui se fait
prendre une façon un peu violente dans
une cave
il croit que c'est ça l'amour il est
simple ils croient que c'est ça l'amour
est alors une vie aux heures 10 je
t'aime voilà la fille dit je t'aime
frappe moi je t'ai non cuit crois que
c'est ça l'amour et après lui il viole
une fille qui est la fille d'un homme
important du village il viole une fille
en croyant que c'est ça l'amour voilà
et alors sont révélés la fin de
l'histoire grâce à un toubib très cool
un peu post soixante huitards qui est
interprété par notre ami patrick
sébastien roy qui prétend que l'ex que
je pense vraiment que l'amour est plus
fort que le valium quoi j'ai eu des
discussions là en tournée on va la
tournée du film avec des psys là dessus
sur le fait que je connais bien les
asiles pas pour y avoir été ou pas y
avoir des copains mais c'est vrai 80%
des gens qui sont dedans ils sont par
manque d'amour c'est un univers qui me
passionne et c'est vrai que je voulais
traiter de ça vous dit que l'avenir de
l'humanité c'est pas le valium c'est
l'amour et c'est vrai que vous êtes
fasciné par cet univers quand vous avez
perdu votre fils vous dites vous même
que vous avez bien failli devenir dingue
et oui c'est pas sûr que tous les fous
soit l'asile il serait donc les gens
qu'ils soient dehors soit pas fou pour
être interné il faut être pour être les
règles pour être interné s'il faut être
dangereux pour soi-même ou pour les
oreilles à la télé pas qu'ils vont être
dedans déjà oui je sais mais c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que je crois je dis pas
qu'il faut pas de cachet du tout mais la
france est le pays qui utilise
pratiquement le plus de tranquillisants
la principale cause de suicide chez les
deux morts chez les jeunes c'est dans
ces suicides donc un manque d'amour
quand tu rentres dans un asile la
première chose que font les
pensionnaires c'est venir te caresser
donc il ya un manque quelque part et
c'est surtout un film sur les a priori
colin
autre endroit vous car vous avez
lancement possible mais si jamais
quelqu'un encore ans d'expérience
personne donne combien de temps je sais
pas marie ma chérie mais qu'est ce qu'un
mari ne pas prononcer un seul mot
le pilote s'est mal ce que tu as fait
très mal
la petite marie marie mais par chance
son bourreau ailes d'un ange alors tout
peut arriver
parce que tu n'es pas malade et si on va
t'aimer vraiment et je voulais six mois
pile pour faire un miracle au ladakh ans
car le lobby laguna jean-marie laissez
nous bosser foutez nous la paix n'est
pas dangereux jeu plus dément le plus
dangereux c'est vous public en france
pendant au nom de quoi au nom de l'amour
absolu pour nourrir solu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des mousquetaires mariton période de
bien pourtant mais pourtant mené seul je
peux rien faire
[Musique]
et que s'ouvrent mme hébert
si je peux tant que fier lui couler la
vie en dôme
kassav et m
c'est un fils de patrick sébastien
réalisé et écrit réalisé par patrick
sébastien et dans lequel il joue et la
chanson c'est ça mon cher
ajouté ma
douleur je suis pas
[Musique]
j'ai donné j'ai donné le sénat raphia
fiori en soi et il est parti et que sa
fiancée de l'époque
ils ont travaillé sur le sur la chanson
i'm a rendu ça lui faisait pas peur
qu'on vous qu'on vous prenne pour un
gourou à force de chanter avec l'amour
absolu et je veux pas faire de sectes
moi je crois ça je veux convaincre un
par un maximum de gens je suis pas le
seul on est plein on savait déjà jésus
qui était comme ça ouais mais comme je
me dis comme je me dis enfin comme je
fais lire à bas le maire qui me parle à
moi vous prenez pour le christ nous est
trop grand c'est de la lucidité
non mais je pense que goutte par goutte
on arrivera à faire comprendre même si
c'est pas la mode aujourd'hui que
l'amour absolu c'est à dire regardez les
gens différemment les respecte et quelle
que soit l'heure leur taille leur poids
leur couleur leur origine sociale ce
quoi qu'il fasse c'est l'avenir je vois
pas par par quoi d'autre on peut passer
moi je vais vous dire un truc je vais
pas entamer une une conversion à l'écran
enfin vous êtes beaucoup plus chrétiens
que ce que vous croyez patrick sébastien
mais sans s'en laissant la croissance
sans la caste mais ses cheveux il ya
plein de symboles rappelle marié zf les
petits c'est pas innocent salim inutile
de joseph alors
bon la critique évidemment ça va être
compliqué parce que c'est vrai qu'à
paris c'est sûr que oui d'abord j'ai eu
du mal à monter le film parce que vous
connaissez personne dans le métier vous
n'êtes pas le fils de quelqu'un vous
n'êtes pas le type à la carte
quelqu'un t'a vous équiper à la carte
oui c'est pas une telle issue et puis je
suis clown à la télé ce n'est pas une
comédie certes tout le monde s'est dit
il serait plus facile pour vous
d'ailleurs de monter une comédie mais
tout le monde attendait que ça serait si
c'est ce qu'il y avait dans le ventre
je crois que le plus beau la plus belle
critique que j'ai eu même pas qu'ils y
arrivent derrière je les ai vu des mecs
de fréquence nord je crois en vous qui a
vu le film et celle à lille et qui m'a
dit je suis rentré dans le cinéma en
reculant parce que je voulais pas y
aller je suis sorti à reculons pas si je
voulais pas en sortir sama ça m'a
vraiment touché mais vous dites vous
partez un peu battus au niveau de la
critique parce que peu importe la
qualité de mon premier film les
professionnels ne vont pas aimer et même
s'ils aiment ils ne diront pas parce que
c'est sébastien basse et un peu ouais
j'ai déjà eu à redire j'ai déjà vu c'est
un peu magique
non là c'est lucide on le sait je veux
dire les mecs de télé tu t'imagines
ça fait des années qu'ils disent de moi
que je suis vulgaire vivons pas d'un
seul coup ce way dire le contraire moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est comme toujours
comme dans tout ce que j'ai fait à la
télé au music hall c les gens c'est
s'élèverait genre mauss et cela c'est
cela qui m'intéresse
alors la production exécutive a été fait
par votre pas votre épouse
on sait démerdé le catering été fait par
ma mère je veux dire on sait quand vous
avez épousé nathalie en fait au départ
vous avez fait ce mariage comme ça pour
faire une fête et puis vous êtes aperçu
finalement que ça vous donner un sacré
équilibré vous dit
à 45 ans c'est la première fois que je
m'appuie sur une femme
ouais parce que jusqu'à présent je c'est
quelqu'un qui le porte est plus fragile
plus fragile que moi-même porte
ouais importe vraiment c'est là que j'ai
vécu ce pas ces temps avec elle on s'est
mariés on s'est marié pour faire un bref
affaire la fin pour se faire plaisir
on s'est marié sur le stade de brive
2000 personnes pour ce soit boots avec
des valses de vienne vois je te réussit
put on va se faire le souvenir génial et
quand on s'est retrouvés le soir on
s'est aperçu que ça va changer quelque
chose
alors que j'en suis au quatrième donc
oui dites moi c'est un peu votre bébé à
tous les deux films à la ouais on a la
malchance de ne pas pouvoir en avoir et
c'est rédhibitoire
c'est notre bébé ouais c'est notre petit
donc on y met toute la tendresse et
maintenant la même dans la forme dans le
sujet qu'on a traitées
c'est ça fait partie des différences
aussi de ne pas pouvoir avoir d'enfant
est-ce que vous en avez un autre en
préparation j'en ai plein j'ai plein
face à la dépendance il fut la marche
est un petit peu on a parlé d'un sujet
quoi sur le fils du lot investi ouais
c'est vrai il est rare est la fille du
travail serait parce que c'est pareil je
trouve que le bois de boulogne que tu
connais aussi en petite manon pascual
habite à côté on est frustré que je sais
je trouve que dans non je trouve que le
bois est un endroit passionnant non
sérieuse l'asie c'est comment patrick
nous c'est vachement bien il se passe
des trucs extraordinaires il ya de la
violence il ya de l'amour il ya ya deux
il ya de la tendresse y a des trucs
cachés il ya des ministres qui viennent
moi j'invite les côtés mais et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une g et ses parts en fait
le scénario je m'éclaire part d'une
histoire
ouais je connais un travesti qu'à une
allure de femme qui ne savait qui est
papa d'une petite main et c'est assez
troublant et c'est une belle et quelque
chose de riche
je te raconte l'histoire la vraie
histoire c'est même au delà de la mairie
scénario ils vont me dire c'est pas
possible
vous savez encore imiter ouais ça
m'arrive est moi un truc là parce que ça
commençait à nous manquer la télé c'est
pas difficile giscard d'estaing non
c'est sûr que c'est pour montrer qu'ils
s'agissent que je faisais collège en
temps je raconte des histoires à la con
non josé mourhino et puisque je faisais
c'est que j'arrivais à prendre la tête
des gens quand je suis là on va faire un
tir rasant je préfère dassa et dassin
c'était ma tête c'était rien du tout je
séchais ma lèvre supérieure si la lèvre
supérieure ont eu lieu à faire on va
faire quelque chose de difficile à faire
bah non mais on va faire comme votre
film ça risque d'être un peu difficile
avec les critiques par avec le public
avec les critiques ont même pas bon pour
le moment ça va encore on voit ça va
très bien alors moi je vais vous faire
une interview et vous allez me répondre
en question que je vais vous poser en
imitant des gens je déteste ça vous
détestez quoi à faire des imitations
comme ça brûle pourpoint mais vas-y n'en
faisait qu'à faire bourvil tout le temps
hambourg il faut le faire pendant trois
heures sans doute en faire d'autres
menaces à la dynamique assureurs de
falla alors que chirac ou chirac
bon c'est bon alors ça s'appelle
l'interview cire pompes on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bougé ouais bah oui je suis quand
il faut tout refaire tout où tout
recommence ou est-ce qu'on peut rappeler
mohamed al fayed
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que vous êtes prêts ouais
ouais c'est une interview ci reprend pas
bah ouais c'est quoi ça ben c'est que je
te sais comme jeu normalement ça
s'appelle l'interview drucker mais je
l'appelle l'interview cire-pompes
patrick sébastien est ce que vous a déjà
dit que vous aviez une vraie belle
gueule pourquoi me dire des choses
pareilles oui avec la tête que j'ai
depuis les oreilles décollées
non j'ai vraiment pas quand je me
regarde dans la glace je sais pas bien
quoi
à montbard patrick
ouais avec une bouche comme ça vous
devez hyper bien embrasser non
tiberi écoutez ma biche ou alors juste
une idée je ne vous expliquer clairement
vous regardez l'appui aussi bien là
alors écouter j arrive elle a réalisé à
brasser là mais non c'est plutôt vers
l'avant c'est pas grave c'est à chacun
comment comment vous fait que votre
charisme vous sortez d'où où je vais
s'il ya un truc que je n'ai pas bien
bougé rien je peux pas te dirai qui tu
es questions à la con je commence à en
avoir plus
[Applaudissements]
comment comment vous faites pour être
aussi facile à vivre tous les jours
ben je sais pas du tout c'est parce que
c'est sûrement dans ma nature profonde
tué sétois par exemple tu es un gars qui
a c'est facile la vie vous aussi à moi
très facile non plus oui tu as été très
gentil avec ta femme tu me l'a dit
d'être un gentil taille et il a une
conception de l'adultère qui est
terrible il me dit toujours su sais
c'est pas trop et puis dans le cul ça
compte pas
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avant je suis allé chercher ma
peine après l'émission pas de problème
car ce mois vous savez ce que signifie
pour les hommes
avoir un nez un peu près mille ans comme
ça écoutez libéraux à voir on est promis
non je suppose que nous ayons en
comparaison un organe sexuel de la même
taille c'est quelque chose de magnifique
c'est quelque chose qui m'a porté ses
associés emmerder je sais plus à quoi
bon me dirais je faire pour finir j'ai
de faire gainsbourg la dernière question
faussement la cigarette que c'était
quand même quelqu'un qui a pu trouver
une cigarette suis là je l'aimé bien
mais j'ai mené mon travail j'ai les
miennes à bon chat en fumée les tienne
moi je rends pas les mêmes je fais sur
scène parce que ça fait rire mais la
balance il balance ouais c'est bien à
moi c'est un truc un nom est tu sais
pourquoi j'aime pas l'odeur ah ouais moi
le pétard j'aime pas ça passe et c'est
pas que c'est pas mon truc que j'aime
pas l'odeur c'est comme les tricks et on
va pousser quoi en fait c'est parce que
je suis un vrai excessif que c'est que
si je me mets le nez dedans c'est fini
au départ c'est avec les biens à marx et
si à la mode dans le showbiz
aya les couloirs tu es tu passes le
titre du tape dans le dos des mecs tu as
les ponts blanche
alors voilà temps à temps pourquoi
t'emmerde
pose ta question pourquoi aucune femme
ne peut vous résistez sucer les
conneries bref c'est pas loin
et l on donne tout le monde tu
t'entraînes affaires drucker tu huawei
mais là surgit arrive non j'avais fait
des questions sur moi j'aime bien moi
aussi léchée michel ya quelqu'un qui
disait que drucker était tellement
gentil quand on est donné un coup de
pied dans les couilles vous demander si
vous n'êtes pas fait mal
[Applaudissements]
bien se voir
ça j'aime bien
ça
si patrick sédation rallume et
j'accueille maintenant la lauréate du
20e prix romy schneider petit le
courreau
clotilde courau mesdames messieurs petit
vous connaissez calais olivier patrick
sébastien alors vous êtes comme je viens
de le dire clotilde courau la lauréate
du 20e prix romy schneider pour en face
de mathias ledoux et guillaume canet a
eu lui lé 20e prix jean gabin pour je
règle mon pas sur le pas de mon père
mais pas pour un film si je savais pas
alors ils voulant pas dit si c'était
pour en face de mathias ledoux et lui
c'était pour jeu règlement pas sur le
pas de mon père de rémi waterhouse
on a appris ce matin on était tous là
bas vous êtes vraiment l'actrice qui
monte en ce moment vous avez une double
actu alors on y va tout de suite j'ai
assez pour la preuve ça c'est pour la
première actu maintenant pour la
deuxième actuellement vous avez vous
avez un film à la fiche bientôt un qui
s'appelle la parenthèse enchantée où
vous incarnez personnage comme ça une
fille au début des années 70 une fille
du mlf et alors al'inverse vous êtes la
semaine prochaine sur scène dans une
pièce où là vous incarnez une [ __ ] le
film c'est la parenthèse enchantée de
michel spinosa avec vincent elbaz
roschdy zem karin viard et géraldine
paillassa sort le 26 avril alors la
parenthèse enchantée c'est une
expression qui a été inventé par
françoise giroud c'est françois giroux a
inventé l'expression nouvelle vague et
elle a inventé une autre expression et
c'était un enfant qui fait ça non elle a
inventé une deuxième expression qui la
parenthèse enchantée
alors la parenthèse à chanter c'est
l'époque qui va de l'arrivée de la
pilule à l'arrivée du sida quoi c'est
l'époque on pas vous en souvenez ouais
ouais on a une bonne pour notre
génération là l'un des vieux est rien et
je crois qu'on a eu le bol de vivre les
vingt années de lui-même de toute
l'histoire de l'humanité on pouvait pas
mourir en faisant l'amour avant il y
avait des sinistres après il ya eu aussi
dans ces cas les justes au mal et nous
on y sera un bonheur et un bonheur
énorme
donc c'est une histoire qui se passe
dans les années 70 et 3 filles la
coincer la sage la militante et deux
garçons le jouisseur et complexes et
donc déjà belle brochette de personnages
alors ils couchent y voilà ces années 70
quoi ils cochis maryse trompent ils se
retrouvent
c'est la fameuse décennies de la
libération sexuelle alors ce qu'on
découvre dans le film c'est un petit peu
ce qui est sorti d'ailleurs de cette
fameuse époque des années 70 c'est que
le plaisir ne mène pas toujours au
bonheur est derrière mais michel
houellebecq qui vont inviter tout à
l'heure vous serez là vous le dira ce
qu'il a fait un bouquin là dessus vous
quelque chose à ajouter
c'est un très beau film que j'aime
beaucoup je l' ai vu avec vous on était
assis à côté il ya une place de libre
et c'est clotilde courau qui est venue
s'asseoir à côté de moi
ah ouais j'ai du pot non mais ça c'est
un beau film est touchant émouvant
sincère drôle et ceux qui n'ont pas vécu
cette époque ça peut leur peur ça peut
permettre de la comprendre un petit peu
mieux comprendre un peu les barreaux
comme nous ils ont été ça on va en
parler des parents en attendant on va
voir un extrait du film années de hausse
et vous avez passé avec succès le stade
de la technique de compression
il est temps si vous en êtes d'accord de
passer à l'étape du cow-boy en promo
chez d'accord et on la tension se dirige
désormais vers la femme il est juste qu
une fois les régulations mieux contrôler
elle puisse donner libre cours aux
manifestations de son décès lundi n'ont
donc pas fait de commentaire que
donnerait son blog donc est mieux se
passer pour commencer placez-vous
imposition de masturbation compression a
l'air très tendre le passage d'une
position à l'autre n'est pas très facile
à réaliser
allez disons nous recommander quelques
répétitions sans pénétration
je passe sur sa patrie l'homme de sa
main gauche doit élever dernière ils
sont rouges dans un champ que j'ai envie
que lui-même dégage saint jean matas
gauche et l'appli de personnes relève
l'agent de la méforme d'un angle à 45 2
oui bon ok tu fais mal mais il a été
pêché un petit peu quand même parallèle
à celui de son partenaire andrew g et
jean barou
syndrome 2 et 3 on dit que la phase
subissent un coussin sous lequel on a
conclu aller simple or tant chez les
gars bras droits de la femme et le bras
ne s'est pas du tout comme ça
la parenthèse enchantée de nice au ray
contre être qu'au tibet pour est notre
invité ce soir c'est assez le film alors
il ya il ya une pièce c'est un malade ou
saas et c'est pas d'hier donc irma la
douce et du 27 avril au 1er juillet mise
en scène de jérôme savary c'est à shalio
alors malade ou c'est une prostituée au
grand coeur c'est ça non ouais ça a été
écrit par bréfort qui était un chauffeur
de taxi qui était le roi de largo qui a
terminé au canard enchaîné ouais avec
100 voilà exactement ça a été les
paroles ont été écrites
enfin la musique a été composée par
marguerite monnot qui a composé qui a
proposé entre audience
oui et l'hymne à l'amour faites gaffe à
ce qu'on pense de pia en france
plusieurs gars calme mais je me suis dit
bon voilà on va se prendre un
journaliste d'entrevue sur la gueule
ouais ses gaffes toile moi j'ai traversé
la grande copine de piaf et kiev devait
jouer la pièce
et puis elle est tombée amoureuse elle
est parti ailleurs voilà et la pièce a
été créée par part
bravo ouais c'est la grandeur du service
public c'est de faire des quiz culturel
de sommes des gens qui chantent pas en
fait c'était un film avec qui charles
matte et shirley mclaine c'est la soeur
de qui warren beatty bravo voilà c'est
la grandeur du service public de faire
des quiz culturel le samedi soir c'est
bien c'est culturel ses missions merde
alors c'est pour ça moi je les regarde
régulièrement des lions dantec taris le
petit enfant qui avec un tintin sont
enfoncés c'est fabrice cents américains
je sais pas si rudy cas les barreaux
quelle est la capitale de la slovaquie
loulou une double en mer tiens tiens
d'un quarantenaire sheikh ahmed 24 ans
et sa jambe jusqu'à sacha guitry mais
c'est parce que je vais en personne
bratislava
amis à lui monsieur manuel va venir vous
filmez presti rien ne bougeait pas et
vous allez être une star pendant trois
secondes voilà c'est formidable le
lendemain au bureau ça peut aider toutes
les gonzesses irons vous chercher des 83
à battice la merci manu voilà un petit
plan sur monsieur bratislava d'autres
non mais pourquoi parce que moi j'ai
l'impression d'un vivier bernard henri
lévy là vous est intéressante parce que
vous êtes le produit de 3 décalage voici
déjà réfléchi à ça non d'abord le
premier décalage leur faisait prendre
conscience soir de votre personnalité
premier décalage vos parents sont des
déclassés déjà un décalage parce que
votre mère s'appelait du pontavice des
renardières peu comme dans le spectacle
de valérie lemercier de la renardière
votre père était d'une grande famille
d'industriels et vos parents cités les
années 68 justement comme dans le film
avait décidé de vivre autrement
en refusant les valeurs traditionnelles
dans lequel avait été coupée depuis
longtemps donc que les mots ne voulait
rien dire on déjà vous vous étiez enfant
de jean piot des parodies visite d'une
façon extrêmement bourgeoise et qui en
fait vivent et un peu baba non ils sont
partis en afrique
voilà ça c'est la deuxième décalage vous
êtes parti en afrique à vos parents sont
partis en afrique vous avez passé votre
petite enfance au bénin vous avez été
élevé pas du tout comme les autres
petits blancs parce que vos parents
justement de cet esprit baba aidant ils
ont mis à l'école municipale de cotonou
alors vous mangiez béni à la banane
sardines grillées et vous aviez une
maison en argile sans eau les
électricité c'est vrai ça partait
souvent bruce wayne dans un petit
village on prête savez aideront qu'on
vivait dans le village qui sont
effectivement des maisons en argile sans
eau sans électricité
voilà messieurs paul tout le temps oui
génial c'était la même époque magnéto
serge
alors vos parents vos parents clotilde
rejeter les biens matériels et vous quoi
ne vais pas complètement la même
conception des choses parce que vous
dites quand même bien matériel engendre
comme une certaine liberté
oui parce qu'à force de voir des east
des huissiers débarquer à la maison et
voir la maison vide et parce que
l'argent c'est pas tellement important
il ya un moment donné on prend
conscience que finalement l'argent c'est
quand même important
j'ai vraiment vu ma mère galéré j'ai
fait une connerie de vous demander de
reboutonner votre chemisier maintenant
ça me manque à dents troisième décalage
oui premier décalage donc vos parents
des classes et 2e décalage l'afrique
troisième décalage vous rentrez en
france
et là c'est le choc après la brousse en
votre mère trouve un poste au lycée
technique d'aubervilliers votre père qui
se retrouvent au chômage
et vous allez dans l'appartement de
votre grand-mère et là ça a été un
effectivement un traumatisme traumatisme
terrible éducation bourgeoise moi et
puis on correspondait pas on n'avait pas
les petites les robes qu'il fallait les
chaussures qu'il fallait donc on était
toujours mis au coin avec ma soeur et
puis moi je vais régulièrement mes
chaussures j'étais mieux
donc il y avait un gros décalage général
alcazar très jeunes parce que vous aviez
alexandre ce alexandre les papas le papa
et la maman d'alexandre était copain
avec les propriétaires l'alcazaba là et
donc
moi on a une éducation très libre sans
aucun interdit donc moi j'allais dormir
chez mon copain alexandre qu'il faisait
en bras chez sa chaussette sale sans foi
passe pour pour le prouver que je
l'aimais assez bien non c'est vraiment
dégueulasse et regarde moi des
chaussettes c'est pas mal c'est beau
ouais ouais j'en ai fait des chaussons
on peut y manger des trucs moins
compliqué maintenant parce que je veux
dire mais c'était bien le cas bon je m
j'avais 7 ans donc on avait le droit de
rentrer alexandre aimait beaucoup une
jeune danseuse qui étaient américains
c'est vrai il était amoureux d'une danse
et il y avait des gros ballons qu'ils
étaient lancés à la fin du spectacle et
moi il n'y avait qu'une seule chose qui
m'intéressait ces sites et ces gros
ballons qu'il fallait que je réussisse à
sortir et il y avait toujours un mec
bourré qui crevait le ballon qui salle
éclate aide à 16 ans vous abandonnez le
lycée neuilly pour vous mais on ne lit
c'était ça a été très court parce que
j'étais vraiment traumatisé donc on a dû
me retirer de l'école on a vu vous
retire ah ben oui pourquoi les marchands
de tout ça après ce que je faisais de
l'herpès je faisais vraiment j'avais des
brevets de l'herpès non c'est vrai
terrible alors au début quand vous avez
commencé à gagner de l'argent au cinéma
ou gagner 150 mille balles sur elisa
vous dites c'est hallucinant parce que
votre soeur et votre mère gagne à peu
près 7000 balle par mois non c'est vrai
gagner 150 mille pâle sur un film c'est
beaucoup et après vous avez réalisé que
finalement au cinéma on travaille pas
tous les jours et que cent cinquante
mille balles par an c'est pas beaucoup
n'en fait pas grand chose
c'est le problème n'est pas on voit
arriver une grosse somme on se dit
[ __ ] génial je vais te claquer et puis
très vite ça peut aussi des impôts
ouais maintenant votre ambition c'est de
toucher le million 1 mon ambition c'est
non
je me demande de vous avez notre
ambition c'est toucher le milliard
non pardon
mon ambition c'est de faire des choses
bien ouais voilà tout simplement le
premier premier rôle c'est doyon en 90
dans le petit criminel était nominé pour
jeunes espoirs aux césars et tout de
suite c'est du poème tout ce qui vous a
été remarqué par hollywood deux partis
faire un film avec paul mazursky tous
les actes qui s'appelait le cornichon
sais pas si j'ai eu de la chance
nalement d'être remarqué par hollywood
qui s'appelle le corps des chances soit
sorti en france le pays non mais je sais
pas si on peut appeler ça de la chance
ça va pas à l'époque j'ai cru que
c'était de la chance mais j'avais oublié
que piquionne ça voulait dire quand on
échoue mais bon voilà l'aventuré tout
mais kirk apprend l'anglais tu dis merde
tu dans le corner chaud alors que
c'était moins drôle c'est en revenant
des etats unis chômage
ouais parce que j'avais entre temps une
réputation caractériel bon moi je crois
pas vous êtes très simple à vivre
donc je me suis chopé une réputation
caractériel et puis j'ai eu du mal a
effectivement à auditionner les gens
voulaient plus travailler avec moi
j'étais à la rame au chômage mais je
crois que ça fait pas c'est le métier
quoi puis après vous être marqué car
bertrand tavernier
bertrand tavernier a été le premier
effectivement à me dire tiens je t'avais
remarquée dans le petit criminel j'ai un
tout petit rôle si ça t'intéresse et ça
faisait un an que j'étais au chômage
donc tout d'un cours effectivement je
les remercier quoi et puis après j'ai
auditionné pour jean becker et il ya eu
elisa et les gens l'ont remarqué puis
j'ai coincé mon pied dans la porte et
j'ai fait cette fois ci faisaient pas
beaucoup dehors et puis voyez votre
carrière millions un million
je n'ai pas encore on va vous faire vous
savez vous connaissez les missions il
faut pas bouger par le jingle vous savez
ça hein
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai fait exprès c'est bon pour casser
les règles un peu savoir les scénarios
croyances si on va voir en quoi vous
croyez
effrayante est ce que vous croyez en
dieu
non vous êtes de déjà est ce que vous
croyez au diable est ce que vous croyez
à la baisse des impôts par laurent
fabius je crois rien je vous croyais aux
extraterrestres à l'homéopathie
vous croyez à l'homéopathie vous croyez
pas c'est que ça me fait toujours rien
est ce que vous croyez au petit signe du
destin ou oui choque pas ne croyez pas
quand on écoute une cassette d'edith
piaf on a les accidents ne mord pas avec
soeur dix fois plus salées la merci
merci je vous préviens la vie éternelle
non est ce que vous voyez au voyante non
elles souffraient que je vais vous
marier non est-ce que non mais le
mariage pour moi non faire des enfants
oui l'idée que vous vous ferez vous
marier le jour de l'année du premier
anniversaire de votre premier enfant
oui enfin je suis crois que ça arrive de
dire des conneries
ouais est ce que vous croyez en la
réincarnation non est ce que vous croyez
aux fantômes non aux anges gardiens non
est ce que vous voyez que le rpr là se
mettent d'accord pour trouver un
candidat à paris en ce sens
concernant les candidatures à la mairie
de paris à quelqu'un qui peut vous aider
c'est le conseiller de jean tiberi c'est
bernard blais n'aura eu
dans leur lettre bonsoir je connais
s'est perfectionnée tient à ce que je
regarde la télévision
olivier cade et clotilde courau qui est
dans un film qui s'appelle la parenthèse
enchantée qui se passe au début des
années 70 j'ai vécu le début des années
70 ce beau oui ça vous avez vous avez
jamais je n'en avais jamais été hippie
ou baba pas vraiment droit vraiment
c'est pas votre style assez mauvais
garçon mais passer ma vie gazaouis oui
alors elle est non loin du but non j'ai
fumé beaucoup c'est juste pas de juin et
alors elle est aussi allée bernard elle
est aussi dans une pièce que vous
connaissez la danse pas une pièce d'or
c'est une comédie musicale qui s'appelle
irma la douce à chaillot mis en scène
par savary et où elle chante à vous
chantez vous connaissez un air là comme
ça de mémoire non mais là c'est
difficile à froid sans gérard daguerre
jardin voire de guerre non bah oui
grande palette je veux pas jouer au foot
je vous [ __ ] l'ambiance en l'air merci
oui à chaque fois que gérard béghin say
je veux je peux tu peux te garantir une
chose tu vas demandé à gérard wey ce
qu'on a raconté tout à l'heure oui sur
edith piaf l'accident donc je fais
raconte oui je venais de poser gérard
daguerre chez nous ah ouais je déconne
pas moi je me colle raisons légales
peuvent être cassé une jambe
quant aux états unis
mais c'est ce à quoi il croyait mais
souvenez-vous déposé chez lui c'est vrai
il était devenu avec moi je courant de
cette histoire un art bled
non c'est la malédiction piaf dire que
lui il écoute des cassettes des sports
parle pas parce que là on arrête on
arrête son portait la poisse des
courriers battre n est pas la foulée ça
y est ça vous savez limité attention pas
là j'ai un trac bien heures bernard bled
vous êtes secrétaire général de la ville
de paris exact vous êtes chef
d'état-major du qg politique de jean
tiberi à la mairie de paris
vous êtes commerçant c'est un petit peu
de ketchup sur le truc rincez les jours
de l'année
vous êtes commissaire général à l'an
2000 voilà ça c'est vos titres officiels
officiellement commissaire général à
l'an 2000 c'est vers l'arc à remplacer
le pos rives moses
quand il a écouté exit piaf bien l'art
officieusement vous est la tête pensante
du maire son éminence grise son âme
damnée son richelieu sont ma'sara vous
sera ce putin way et vous êtes aussi
vous avez un autre surnom qui est assez
drôle c'est monsieur un dossier paraît
lui parce qu'il paraît vous dit toujours
on a ce qu'il faut sur tout le monde tu
as soon as dessus sur moi là ça
m'inquiète beaucoup mangé des fiches à
il a défendu mais comme j'ai des filles
sur vous et des fissures moines des
choses monsieur bled vous êtes en train
de la mairie de paris en 1962 il ya
trente huit ans 38 ans est pas d'hier
lors vous êtes le nouveau du grammairien
célèbre bled ça c'était votre votre
oncle un le grammairien blaton 30 ans
vous êtes le fils d'un petit
fonctionnaire d'une vendeuse
je vais penser votre enfance à malakoff
vous avez noté c est vous êtes devenu
agent deux agents de bureau s'est passé
là on est marié à ces jeunes vus
rapidement deux enfants il était obligé
pour doubler votre salaire de les ventes
du fromage sur les marchés à 6h du matin
oui ça c'est vrai sauf que je ne voulais
pas mon salaire
ah bon ça suffisait pas doubler votre
sert à l'époque je gagnais par mois
s'ouvre signé par jour c'était vers 500
francs oui on s'est longtemps
au début j'ai entendu ça en attendant
que c'est très bien mais il marchait ça
rapportait de sang froid un mois vous
restez pas la jouer vers votre femme
était obligé d'être nourri ce exact elle
avait cinq enfants dans votre petit
appartement à levallois enfin tout à
jeudi tout ça parce que monsieur de
l'aide a commencé durs dans la vie
ça ne me semblait pas très dur voilà
vous êtes rentré la mairie vous été
recommandé par votre grand-mère là vous
avez monter tous les échelons
alors quand chirac est arrivé c'était le
début de votre réussite parce qu'il vous
a fait tout de suite confiance jacques
chirac quand il est arrivé en 77 moi
j'étais déjà là depuis quinze ans et il
se trouve que le service où je travaille
à ce moment là que les services du
protocole est un service était très
proche de lui et très rapidement on
s'est connus on s'est aimés de
bernadette aussi oui au chu la famille
vous aimez beaucoup bernadette oui
j'aimais bien aussi je continue à bien
l'aimer
vous avez des jacques chirac a
verrouillé le système parisien quoi ce
qui veut dire s'appuyer plus sur
l'administration que sont les élus
jacques chirac c'est un fonctionnaire le
métier quelque sorte donc quand il est
arrivé là à la ville il a trouvé des
jeunes administration qui était solide
préfectorale
donc c'est vrai qui s'est assez
rapidement appuyer sur ce qui existait
mais il s'est aussi appuyé sur les élus
et sur certains élus notamment 95
évidemment c'est là c'est le bonheur
vous embrasser par la dette
oui c'est vrai ça sur dix que le moment
était un peu exceptionnel on est c'est
presque surréaliste
il est un peu plus de 20 heures le
résultat de l'élection présidentielle
est connue
jacques chirac est seul dans son bureau
et que sa femme et claude chirac a
personne dans les couloirs de l'hôtel de
ville
claude a fait le ménage c'est plus h il
ya plus un chapelain journaliste
personnes s'est clos qui faisait le
ménage à la mairie 2 oui ça et les des
temps sont difficiles et moi je me
trouve là à ce moment là c'est vrai
chirac sort il est président et madame
chirac est avec lui l'aude est avec lui
on est tout seul dans ce grande cette
grande maison et là je sais pas
spontanément
si j'avais mal et je lui dis j'ai envie
de vous embrasser voilà alors c'est une
pulsion qui a été unique
un cas unique parce que
ça unis dans sa ville dans la vo du
lingala mais peut-être dans la saison
c'est la première fois qu'elle m'a
embrassé l'herbe rase un peu c'est
nécessairement unique bien et là vous
devenez alors la branche chirac devient
président la république vous devenez
confident de tibéri enfin très proche de
de jean tiberi vous l'aidez beaucoup
voulaient d'abord quand il ya eu la
sphère du rapport bidon de xavière ouais
je pense à lui parce que je n'ai pas
particulièrement et dvd quand on s'est
aperçu tout évident au reims et par moi
j'ai pas lu lampe
j'ai lu talent vous y rendre oui et bien
l'or continue de trouver un truc énorme
c'est que la semaine dernière il y avait
eric raoult et à votre place et un
moment eric raoult était devenu jeune
tout boulistes
alors ça m'intéressait de savoir quelle
est l idéologie du jeune tout boulistes
c'était un peu compliqué mapad revient à
journée ça dure et alors vous il ya une
tentative de putsch to boney urbanisme
sait quelque chose
on peut être tout bonne ici à des
tentatives de putsch tout beau nice et
alors là vous avez aidé jean tiberi
contre la tentative de putsch tout
moniste et vous avez eu cette phrase qui
est dans votre autre manière
vous avez dit je veux les voir à poil
mais c'est un peu comme l'interview qui
précède mais ce n'était pas exactement
la même chose
c'est une image oui mais les voir à poil
ça veut dire avec la corde au cou et en
vous demandant pardon tout simplement se
trouvait un peu démuni par rapport à
tous les avantages qu'ils peuvent avoir
dans leur vie quotidienne à l'hôtel de
ville
ouais je voulais savoir simplement
savoir si leurs convictions étaient plus
fortes que les avantages annexes
je me suis aperçu qu'en réalité je
m'étais pas trompé c'était plutôt les
habitudes qui sont davantage que les
conventions c'est comme ça que ça s'est
délité assez vite
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer là où
les repères là maintenant comment il va
être choisi ce candidat là c'est pour le
moment il n'y a pas de là franchement si
vous pouviez m'éclairer moi c'est ça me
rendrait service qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour être dans un monde meilleur qu'est
ce qu'on fait si les écarts qui sont
présents
de plus en plus grands il ya vraiment
des gens qui sont en train de crever la
dalle et y en a d'autres qui s'en
mettent plein les poches
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement
le rpr le bidule
qu'est-ce qui secoue la classe à l'école
et qu'ils soient dans son dos entre le
travail et la merde je travaille sur la
santé qu'il est super content on brasse
et bernadette chirac quoi c'est super ça
n'a pas de rapport avec la précarité non
medef c'est un autre sujet ça me sujet
je les écoute pas moi parce que
concrètement ça ne change rien ça fait
des années qu'on dise que ça change et
on se retrouve systématiquement dans la
merde et raison tu prends le métro tu as
des gens qui crèvent la dalle quoi y'a
un truc oil alors marre de nous faisons
nous berner comme ça il y en a marre
elle a un peu raison que le tilt dans le
sens où on a l'impression qu'on prend un
temps fou à choisir qui va reconnaît
qu'il a choisi les courses et de
régulation d'un champ dans la poche il
s'éloigne passé de la même façon bien
merde j'ai juste dit un truc c'était
qu'effectivement apparemment les riches
étaient de plus en plus riches et les
pauvres de plus en plus c'est vrai ça
sinon c'est nous
d'accord mais ce qui m'embête un peu
c'est tout ce temps comprend pour les
parce que pendant ce temps les mecs qui
se pencher tout ce temps comprend pour
élire celui qui va représenter cas pas
les mêmes sied à 2,13 de l'oreille des
6,7 me patrick si cette mecque à bernard
bergé mais quand on regarde si claire
lui c'est pas de sa faute si à trois
autres candidats quoi on se désintéresse
totalement ce qu'est ce qui est terrible
bien sûr terrible c'est des citoyens
actifs bien sûr moi je trouve qu'il ya
un truc quand même qui est que j'ai
observé et est ce que est ce que quelque
part on va y mettre fin un jour les sans
abri les restos du coeur ça devrait pas
exister
on a les moyens en france deux filets du
blé pour qu'ils aient plus de sans abri
moi je crois enfin ma théorie à moi
c'est quand on dit qu'à une manipulation
c'est que cette petite couche de gens
qui sont très malheureux on entretient
volontairement pour que la couche qui
au-dessus ferme sa gueule en dix ans
mais il ya plus malheureux que nous et
c'est pour ça qu'on nous montre sans
arrêt des gens qui sont sans abri et
c'est alors que si on veut
si on veut si l'étape vraiment parce que
c'est une urgence si on veut vraiment là
bas tous ces gens là les sens ça doit
plus exister dans notre société on a les
moyens financiers je me demande je me
demande si vous démarrez 6,6 en a un qui
aura les couilles et un jour de dire ça
on a les moyens de l'éradiquer
parfaitement et c'est vrai qu'après on
va se retrouver qu'une couche beaucoup
plus grande de mecs qui sont à cinq
mille balles par mois pour dire
maintenant c'est nous qui sommes en bas
on va gueuler voilà peux vous répondre
en une
en une phrase là dessus parce que le
problème on va pas le régler non soir
pour et ses avions mais je suis j'avais
la capacité de les faire je ferais bien
parce que ce que vous disiez
actuellement ça tombe pile poil parce
que en ce moment là toute la journée
d'aujourd'hui est la moitié de la
journée de demain
nous avons organisé à l'hôtel de ville
de paris
les états généraux de la solidarité
c'est moi même qui ai mis ça au point
avec le maire ya plus de 18 mois et ça
fait pendant 18 mois nous avons
travaillé avec les 35 associations de
paris caritative qui sans exception
il parie sur non mais moi je m'occupe
que de paris c'est à séoul et pour plus
tard on peut s'occuper d'autre chose si
vous pensez du président si j'ai un
destin national
d'autres choses mais pour l'instant
j'arrête mon mes capacités aux
périphériques c'est déjà pas si mal ça
fait déjà 2 million cent mille personnes
déjà par le plus grave tout ce que vous
intéresser à ces sujets là de précarité
qui sera toujours à des dates
anniversaires des dates de l'élection
c'est du blabla mais ça soulage souvent
ya pas jamais avant tout genre au moment
des élections
mais ça c'est pas qu'on se rembrunit
mais en politique pour écouter ce que je
vous propose camarades c'est de
suspendre cette ag ses parents
mon argent la brande m côté salle
[Applaudissements]
et qu'at-il qu'est ce que vous avez fait
de dire dans ce journal que vous
voudriez gagner un million au prochain
film il va être obligé de vous le donnez
un jeu demande de participer mais voilà
voilà bien alors c'est pas grave je
continue avec monsieur je continue avec
monsieur blade donc les candidats en
présence
clotilde je vois que vous avez été élevé
par des parents fait sentir vous n'êtes
pas appris la discipline à la maison ils
étaient 68 voting bien avec la table
jamais ça je suis sûre bien
alors monsieur blade eux
donc à françoise de panafieu jetant des
candidats à la candidature rpr pour la
mairie de paris
edouard seguin il ya ce gain il ya
edouard balladur et jean tiberi bien sûr
qui est déjà mère bon dans une bonne
ambiance
quand on vous parle de françoise de
panafieu imams face aux signes de
l'égorgement non ça c'est vrai ce outre
et ça fait outrées vous fait quoi comme
signe ça où ça s'est passé selon le
moment donc pas la fin vous n'êtes pas
très pote avec panafieu je la connais
depuis longtemps voilà notre 21 ans
alors quand il est question de balladur
vous dites c'est une vous dit en parlant
jack lang à l'époque où tu es candidat
vous dites oui toute façon jacques lent
quand il était candidat il a fait autant
d'interventions de balladur quand il
était conseiller
bon c'est à dire aucune donc ça vous
n'êtes pas pour balladur vous êtes
parent enfant pardon vous interrompre
encore mais quand à l'intérieur d'une
même famille politique comme ça vous
balance et x3 voulez vous fait mal bail
qu'on croit après et je savais que je
suis un ami du président je parle de ma
vie parce que j'aime l'homme point je ne
fais pas de politique
j'aime l'homme boit lapointe et je ne
m'intéresse pas mais quand je vois sa
famille moi c'était des coups de fusil
ont de ce fait rire c'est pas crédible
après alors dans ce cas là il faut que
le chef de famille interviennent voilà
on va y venir on va y venir y en a il
serait temps que le parrain et si on ne
fait pas nécessaire
bon il ya ce bien après
ce je reviendrai bientôt en voyage
officiel en france ce gain ce gars c'est
un peu ce qu'a bien l'anglais séguin
s'est un peu mieux
oui ouais vous avez déclaré en parlant
de seguin sa vision du gaullisme me
convient oui c'est pas un enthousiasme
lui a répondu en parlant de vous
d'ailleurs bernard bled est une vraie
compétence alors est ce que vous seriez
pas en train de lâcher tiberi pour ce
gars c'est pas possible je ne sais pas
lâcher quelqu'un que je manque que je
soutiens ce qui est dit et qu'il ne
m'est jamais arrivé ça fait partie des
valeurs du rpr de ceux qui ont des
connaissances et des valeurs du harper
de passage et se lâcher mais pas se
lâcher
alors s'ils commencent à temps et
comment ça va se passer la commande vous
vous dites si le candidat rpr à la
mairie de paris n'est pas choisie par un
vote des militants à bulletin secret il
n'aura aucune légitimité où elle n'aura
aucune légitimité et donc tiberi ira
jusqu'au bout
voilà je susceptibles d'y aller mais
comme vous savez qui aura pas de vote
des militants à bulletin secret sait
rien il rira jusqu'au bout je ne sais
pas alors maintenant dans la vieille
question n'est pas une importante
d'ailleurs le cercle t-il
c'est pourquoi tiberi tient parce qu'il
sait des choses mais j'ai apprécié
est-ce que tiberi c'est des choses sur
la gestion de l'hôtel de ville
du temps de chirac qui peut embêter
chirac pour sa réélection en 2002 est ce
que c'est pour ça que tiberi tiens
tiberi tient pour plusieurs raisons et
celle là est la plus mauvaise des
raisons
la première raison c'est que il est
depuis 35 ans élu parisien sa seule
vision politique c'est paris il s'est
toujours battu pour paris et il a envie
de continuer à se battre pour paris bon
vous voyez bien la même qu'il ya des
mouvements contre lui l'entente vous dit
al peuple qui gronde dans la rue vous
dites on s'en fout on a le double
vitrage
reeves vous me lisez beaucoup aussi jeu
j'admire quelque part je parle pas du
personnage et tout c'est avec ce qui
prend dans la gueule comment il tient
debout encore la rue jaffa est ce qu'on
voit c'est un truc mais cher pourquoi
s'en tient à vue du couple vous pourquoi
vous me berna on tire on tient parce que
on est solide et bien dans nos baskets
c'est tout sinon tient pas moi je vous
dis que tiberi doit savoir des trucs
gênante pour chirac parce que sinon il
ya longtemps qu'il serait plus là voilà
vous dit faux seins et par exemple quand
on vous quand on vous parle des
responsables d'eads est fausse facture
des emplois fictifs avant 1995
vous vous dites sur une chaîne
concurrente mais néanmoins ami il faudra
faire une recherche en paternité il
faudrait faire une recherche en
paternité
ouais c'est une manière de dire tu vas
dire d'y recevoir chez nous fait chier
en balance tout bas non balance rien du
tout de la forêt sans savoir ce qu on a
balancé journée attendait bernard quand
tiberi me jean balan tiberi dit je
pourrais dire des choses
oui c'est retenez moi ou je fais un
malheur quoi il a rien dit attendez il
addition touche un ami de chirac
c'est lui en parlant de lui à la chirac
si on touche à un ami de chirac le rpr
peut tirer un trait sur les municipales
les législatives et les présidentielles
quand il est touché à paris il est
intouchable
alors un jour il a dit ça en réalité
c'est votre collègue elkabbach qui lui a
dit il a dit il a répété derrière je
suis intouchable en réalité ce qui
voulait dire à ce moment là c'est pas
qu'il était intouchable la manière
indienne mais qu'il était intouchable
uniquement parce qu'un maire quand il
est élu maire il reste maire je trouve
ou rien d'autre que si tiberi est
intouchable
vous savez bien que chirac aussi est
intouchable puisque avant de partir du
conseil constitutionnel roland dumas lui
à la rendu judiciairement intouchable
suivant mais c'est le conseil
consultatif ready l'agglo juridiction de
ce pays que vous laissez pas c'est une
responsabilité qui lui incombe de
retirer entre nous vous le connaissez
bien vous voyez tous les jours pourquoi
ils cherchent pas pourquoi il cherche
pas une sortie honorable mais pourquoi
voulez vous qu'ils cherchent une sortie
n'a pas de raison qu'il n'y a qu'une
seule à être élue la même ici à qu'une
seule chose qui vaut même si on croit on
ne croit pas la démocratie moi je crois
démocratie le seul moyen
deux sorties ou de ne pas sortir c'est
de se présenter devant des électeurs
si les électeurs vous dise tu es bon tu
restes ils votent pour lui si l'unité
pas bons on aime pas ils votent pas pour
lui pays sans drame
c'est la seule règle qui vaut tout le
reste c'est du bidouillage est-ce que
clotilde courau est ce que vous allez
vous vous hein vous vous intéressez aux
élections municipales à bahreïn
sincèrement non
[Musique]
vient alors bernard bled vous êtes un
homme de coups dont on va vous faire une
interview de coups à deux coups on va
vous faire une interview dernier coup en
état
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dernier coup dur le dernier coup dur la
candidature de balladur halo reach
oui m'avait déjà 3 et wii dernier coup
de coeur
dernier coup de coeur pour l'interview
de françoise de panafieu dans l way qui
dit quoi parle dit beaucoup de choses et
elle landi et sa famille andy aussi il
ya une chose qui m'a intéressé c'est que
sa soeur dit quand elle était petite
il y avait une grande famille cette
famille c'est de sept frères et soeurs
je crois que sept ou huit
et elle était là elle est née donc a été
la reine ouais et nous étions ses
esclaves et on lui apportait le savons
les choses seront un truc à moi donc ça
va ça m'a vraiment intéressé un peu
peut-être aussi inquiétée par la pana
facile si si bien
bien dernier coup de poing d'un
collaborateur qui suit déjà manqué de
respect comme étant un peu un peu loin
de mes préoccupations politiques au delà
dernier coup de folie elle s'ouvre le
soutien permanent à jean tiberi
ouais dernier coup de foudre françoise
de panafieu bernadette chirac bernadette
chirac devrait pas trop avec votre femme
vous mois dernier coup de gueule alors
ça le dernier coup violent et permanent
ouais mais cécilia c'était il ya une
heure et demie et les méchants faut pas
qu'ils ressemblent pour lyon 3 1 peu
bled il faut savoir si ces raspoutine
richelieu ce sera un napoléon iii
physiquement franchement c'est juste un
peu plus tendre à l'endroit d'un gain et
vous savez que ce gars est fair livres
sur napoléon iii je suis l'ami beaucoup
napoléon iii je sais rien je sais je
sais tu es un grand empereur voilà
dernier coup de pub
bassila c'est vraiment elle vous aide
pas beaucoup mais non mais c'est bien
parce que je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
qui dit ce n'est pas en un seul clic est
vrai dire est plus beau que la sincérité
de nos derniers clous c'est fini c'est
fini
dernier coup de rouge eh ben c'est ya
deux heures oui je vais m'engager tout
cas effet la cave de l'hôtel de ville
d'angers fait la cave de l'hôtel de
ville
ouais quand même cette bouteille c'est
un championnat
quinze mille bouteilles quinze mille
bouteilles mesdames messieurs et le
dernier coup de chapeau bien le mot
dernier coup de chapeau c'est celui que
j'ai donné à jean tiberi encore à sa
sortie de l'hôpital parce que ça
correspondait à ce moment là une
campagne de presse
extravagante et je trouve que le courage
qui est manifeste en permanence mérite
un vrai coup de chapeau
dernier coup de poker c'est celui qu'on
joue en ce moment c'est la partie qu'on
joue cependant c'est celui-là de l'année
coup de poker
et pour finir dernier coup de rein
avant-hier sa vie à lui
merci bernard bled alors vous allez
regarder le match mercredi soir qu'ils
allaient bordeaux way for me l' énorme
un moment très rare ces temps dans les
progressions étaient géniales unix sait
jamais dans le football alors nous
accueillons maintenant avec vanessa
demouy christophe hogard de calais
donc soit on avait ça bonsoir que ça
alors bravo merci ça lui christophe
estève walesa walesa christophe enchanté
jolie chemise on l'a vécu comment vas tu
racontais nous parce qu'on était tous
devant la télé bah disons qu'on s'y
étaient bien préparés comme on a
l'habitude de le dire même si ça peut
choquer certaines personnes on joue les
matches pour les gagner
allez même si cette équipe de bordeaux
avait quand même un goomba
d'internationaux on a on s'est préparés
bat logiquement comme contre strasbourg
et puis bon on a cru en nos chances et
on a défendu fièrement les couleurs du
nord pas de calais magnéto
m
barack obama makes you
si tu es
saleh
[Musique]
m
oui
après
ma
m
en tous les cas bravo ça s'est passé
comment avec les bars de liste est
méchant avec vous certains 7,1 disons
qu'ils vous ont taclé un peu et nous
venons mais bon ça c'est les aspects du
jeu nous aussi je pense qu'on a eu des
tacles et faire quelquefois quand même
quoi
mais disons qu'il ya eu des
comportements cool et d'autres moins
cool mais bon qui par exemple s'est mal
comporté un garçon comme dugarry n'a pas
été à la hauteur de son statut je
pensais
ouais dugarry s'est mal comporté oui
mais bon plutôt que de s'attarder sur
les mauvais comportements que je retiens
les les mots de remerciements qu'on a eu
des différents joueurs et ça ça reste
marquée qu'au et mario vous allez c'est
le vôtre la wii vais l'offrir à quai à
mon nom que celui déjà offert avant la
bce
c'est un cadeau que je vais faire des
jeux offerts déjà contre contre
strasbourg a à l'occasion du quart de
finale et le jour de mon anniversaire en
plus de mes 25 ans allait c'était un
moment inoubliable déjà pour moi quoi
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
budget du club de bordeaux ses 189
millions et le budget du club de calais
c'est moins un million sept
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal hein vous
avez battu ville qui était de la en d2
cannes en d2 strasbourg en dea et là
vous avez battu bordeaux que quand même
une des plus grandes équipes françaises
quoi quand même bruit ouais c'est dû à
quoi la niaque balagna tu ne manges
pense qu'on comme je vous l'aï dit tout
à l'heure on se prépare pour pour ses
événements à répétition d'un on a un
coach qui est qui et qui est derrière
nous et qui bat oui comment il va votre
coach là lazano ça ça va un peu mieux il
a eu un petit malaise dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi après le match oui je
pense que c'était un peu du aussi ce cas
la collation il a pratiquement rien
manger d'après ce que j'ai pu entendre
non c'est celui de ces sud bordeaux
qu'écouter pia non mais ça on a eu des
nouvelles rassurantes et je pense qu'un
peu de repos lui et lui fera du grand
bien
alors il sera sur pieds pour le 7 mai au
stade de france donc j'espère contre
contre nantes
oui c'est fou parce qu'ils l'ont pas ils
ont failli pas jouer la coupe de france
a c'est vrai les problèmes de pognon ne
les fait pas la jouer cette coupe c'est
exact parce que mon disons que diverses
instances ont voulu nous imposer le le
match était joué une telle heure et puis
on est quand même un club amateur
bon nombre de nos supporters sont les
ouvriers on trouvait pas normal et
logique qui vient
c'est rose et à quoi ouais tu vis qui
viennent qui viennent nous voir et
doivent poser une journée de congé pour
venir à ce match quoi qui est ce que les
joueurs
christophe est ce que des joueurs du
club de calais qui ont été obligés
d'aller travailler jeudi matin dernier
jeudi matin n'ont pas ce que je dis
c'était une journée off quand même
c'était une journée off pour certains
certains d'entre nous moi
personnellement je passe mon brevet
d'état pour pour devenir éducateur
sportif 1er degré je me suis rendu à
liévin où là j'ai rencontré mes
collègues de formation et où j'ai passé
une journée avec les jeunes et je me
suis vraiment éclaté kung fu en plus bon
vous êtes vraiment amateur mater des
emplois-jeunes vous bossez au centre
communal d'action sociale c'est vraiment
à vous aider les jeunes à faire des cv
ou à trouver des cdd basse et si c'est
ma vocation j'ai la vocation du social
j'accueille comme vous l'avez dit des
jeunes qui sont demandeurs d'emploi
je les aide à les insérer ou les
réinsérer dans le milieu professionnel
et puis bon bah de les aider au mieux à
travers leur parcours leurs motivations
et leurs compétences quoi vous faire une
copine un appui c'est à la mode les
actrices avec les footballeurs en fait
guère
c'est la première fois depuis la
création de la coupe de france en 1918
que que ça arrive quoi c'est énorme
la cvo pison landed puisque d un petit
peu ce genre de compétition de couper et
quand ils commencent à voir l'embellie
comme ça il ya une dynamique de la
victoire qui fait que tu es athée
intouchable quoi tu as des tripes et
d'ordre c'est penser un petit pot
danemark en coupe d'europe quelques
années l'équipe que tu attends pas qui
doit même pas tu l'as et ça c'est la
marque sera c'est danemark été un peu
l'invité surprise on file à la pression
des médias
c'est cette pression et puis et puis ça
devient il aventure c'est ce cadre
fabuleux dans le sport c'est l' aventure
humaine moi je fais jusqu'à la finale
d'une coupe d'europe qu'on ait gagné
l'aventuré humaine au bout d'un moment
tu est intouchable
c'est énorme c'est vous c'est les plus
belles plus beaux moments à vivre
bon ben là bravo et soul et qu'on vous
dise c'est génial on a tous vivraient
avec vous
vernon wells un peu avec nous là si ça
vous dérange pas ben nous on est ravi de
vous avoir attendez on vous adore là
vous êtes devenus des stars nationales d
idole nationale
moi je suis ravi d'être là alors ça va
me remémore alors vanessa demouy
enfin nous oui alors avant de parler
avec vanessa de mouiller je sors les
gens célibataires ok j'ai fait écouter
un disque j'adore plus que tout
[Musique]
assad ordre
c'est un plaisir que je me faire moi
parce que j'adore ce disque on n'était
pas nombreux à la doré mais ça c'est
quand même quand c'est sorti ses sorties
en quelle année vanessa quatre ans il ya
quatre ans et ça n'a quand même vendu 50
mille exemplaires non voilà c'est moi
j'ai fais partie des gens qui l'ont aimé
ce disque ça vous plaît cannes
oui beaucoup très bien
kit
joli nom vient dans mon rêve de finir
j'adore cette chanson me fait très
plaisir en la mettant c'est
enregistrable bien ce soir c'était donc
oui c'était enregistré abbey road en
flux streaming jeu rien c'est là où les
beatles ont fait la plupart delà de leur
disque vous êtes rare entre télé vous
avez dit j'avais besoin de faire un
break de changer d'image c'est mieux
j'avais pas vraiment besoin de changer
d'image c'est j'avais besoin que les
gens se change d'image qui s'appelle moi
mais j'ai pas vraiment changé j'évolue
en tout cas j'espère c'est tant mieux
t'as pas pris un petit peu non non non
non non non elle est toujours vous êtes
toujours à 46 kg aux accords mais vous
êtes gros si c'est bien mais c'est bien
tu étais beaucoup mieux dans la vie
stabiliserait a perdu d'ailleurs
vraiment à 46 très bon super régime donc
voila j'aimerais d'accord donc c'est
peut-être même 48 vous mesurez vous
mesurez pas ce que vous connaissent pas
embêtés vanessa on n'embête pas tant le
chanteur lui dire qu'elle est jolie
bon cela qu'aucune mesure 1 mètre 69
vous dites 70 dans les interviews mais
moi je sais que c'est 70 ans de vie
sains ont parfois c'est les autres
15 10 est ce que vous avez toujours les
mêmes mensurations
non je fais pas 90 58 88 90 c'est
marrant parce que comme toutes les
filles jolies vous vous aimez pas
tellement ça c'est un truc c'est un truc
c'est comme toutes les filles je crois
ah bon moi chaque fois que j'avais une
fille jolie elle me dit j'aime pas vous
vous dites par exemple j'aurais plus
grande d'avoir la peau très macho
cheveux noirs frisés des grands yeux
enfin je vous êtes mais this way je dis
ça quand j'ai très très jeune déjà passé
ça vous avez j'apprends à m'accepter
mais je crois que on le remarque plus
sur les filles qui sont pas trop moche
parce que tout simplement on leur dit on
était pas mal tu es que c'est comme ça
devrait quand même plus facile on le dit
jamais aussi qu'ils sont pas très gâtée
par la nature mais a priori elles sont
aussi complique c'est que les autres
savez vous aimiez pas votre poitrine à
l'époque maintenant c'est fini ça c'est
pas plus et pas que j'y mets pas ma
poitrine c'est que tout le monde en
parlait donc au bout d'un moment ça
gueule sauf moi c'est bon joli
[Applaudissements]
bien avant vous venez de terminer
justement parce que bon on a connu tous
vanessa dans des séries télévisées
vous venez télévisés qu'on va mettre est
vendu dans 35 pays je veux dire ce n'est
pas non plus on est terminée un long
métrage
je vais le marquis qui est réalisé par
gilles paquet brenner et qui est écrit
par virginie despentes est acquis avec
vous alors dans ce film il ya plein de
médias patrick bruel c'est tony bedi
mewen marion cotillard c'est bien bas
niveau c'est que tu joues juste là à
quoi je joue ce sac c'est pas le mien il
ressemble mais c'est pas mon sac
où est mon sac souchier oui quel sac
mais despatie
oui oui je sais pas de quoi tu
où est mon sac sushis je compte jusqu'à
3 vanessa démunis dans le marc hé ouais
c'est d'ailleurs ce mannequin non mais
c'est surtout hallucinant parce qu'ils
sont plein montage ouais mon petit
morceau vous avez beaucoup de courts
métrages c'est cette année temps vous
avez même été un moment j'ai pensé à
faire lara croft la version cinéma de
lara croft seulement ils ont pris
angelina jolie bison pas eu tort justo
pas mal elle joue très très bien
ouais mais il voulait une américaine de
départ 1 mais c'est vrai vous avez
failli faire la suite de neuf semaines
et demie on m'a proposé le film m'a
donné un senior qui était très très bien
mon personnage était très très bien donc
dans le script que j'ai eu c'est un
personnage n'y avait absolument pas de
scènes dénudées y avait rien du tout qui
se passait avec mickey rourke un café
les essais tout se passait très très
bien on faisait le stylisme ont préparé
le personnage puis d'un seul coup le
film se faisait en anglais quand même
donc leur dîme ce serait bien que j'aie
lustres et en anglais c'était pas le mal
existe à poils du début à la fin je vous
des trucs sur le monde avec mickey
rourke
c'est là vous deviez vais chez le lécher
le ventre de milk héros que vous aimez
pas lécher les vendre 6 mai dans
l'intimité
ouais est-ce que vous embrasse auriez
des chaussettes un truc comme ça
est-ce que par amour vous embrasse
seriez des chaussettes 100 x 100 x par
preuve d'amour
pourquoi pas à envoyer ses foies gras
mais ça vous êtes vous vouliez travail
aux etats-unis en fait parce que vous
êtes là bas on vous juge sur votre
volonté de travailler pas sur votre
image et moi j'ai l'impression que les
gens parlent de moi où j'entends parler
de moi ou quelqu'un vient de répéter un
truc et l'entendue qui parle de
quelqu'un d'autre
donc au bout d'un moment c'est chiant
d'être toujours juste de se justifier de
mois en mois je fais pas des auditions
faut que je rencontre des gens et j'ai
trois rendez-vous pour déjà leur faire
admettre que je suis pas la bimbo et je
vais pas arriver en
dans six nations le ton se fait beaucoup
de mal avec cette image de barbie
choucroute est un peu mais messi cité
dans classe mannequin
ah ouais mais vous connaissez pas classe
mannequin zoetee's jeunes impatients pas
dans le cornichon aux états unis était
partie tourner aux états unis un château
dans le cornichon beckham danny aiello
dans le corps du chanteur
les abbés la hausse et où il y avait des
gens qui étaient très peu des gens pas
mal mais c'est ce qu'elle fait vanessa
vanessa elle a tellement envie de jouer
on apprend tellement pour une bimbo
comme elle dit que des fois elles
arrivent pour montrer qu'elle peut jouer
des rôles de mère elle arrivait avec son
petit frère dans les castings pour faire
croire qu'elle était maman c'est vrai
parce que moi il ya un truc est très
chiant il ya toujours quelque chose
certaine je donne mon nom c'est alors je
suis trop vieille
je suis trop jeune je suis pas le
personnage je suis trop sexy à croire
que je suis pas une gonzesse moi je
n'existe pas fait aussi au la ville de
mons
[Musique]
mais si vous êtes une bande s vachement
joly moi je demande que ça les
transformations que c'est ici j'en rêve
même là dedans il faut remarquer m'a
proposé de transformer de changer un peu
les trucs mais c'est vrai qu'on le pont
pour aller vachement plus loin et
j'adorerais le faire d'ailleurs vanessa
le dit quand on a fait de la télé on est
tourné un paria quoi on est on est
marqué c'est vrai mais c'est difficile
aussi pour une débutante en cours et moi
on m'a carrément dit tu serais a connu
ce serait pire est moins dur je ne sais
pas combien de temps ça rien on sait
rien n'en sais rien je dirais que
vanessa les réalisateurs francis ont
gardé de vous l'image d'une héroïne de
sites comme hyper maquiller un peu comme
ça quoi
magnéto serge
on
carrément cinéma rouge il faut balayer
pour le rôle de raphaël florent hockey
vendus en fait pour elle ça ne sera pas
victoire ça sera linda mais ce sera
quand même très bien
[Musique]
très laid
jamais
bien
c est
[Musique]
un succès planétaire
la série a été exportés dans plus de 30
pays avec des versions parfois exotiques
une panne et chats débrouille bien et
vous êtes tellement marqué ça faisait
tellement pesé qu'à un moment vous avez
voulu arrêter et vous dites je peux pas
me passer de ce métier évidemment vous
mêmes voulu arrêter tellement c'était
pesant d'avoir fait ça va vous avez
vraiment envie en même temps malgré ça
vous continuer parce que vous avez envie
de faire ça depuis toujours quand vous
étiez pitt dans la salle de bain vous
jouiez à la remise des césars tout seul
un seul problème
enfin si la nsa se marier en septembre
en
donc ça ça va mais je vous rassure pas
avec un faux bond à la hype avec un
footballeur nord avec stéphane heureux
stéphane à heureux stéphane hélas non ce
qu'aulas rocard
collaro c'est sophie favier alors vous
avez quelque chose de commun avec
clotilde courau du fait d'être jeudi
toutes les coiffes et à peu près pareil
c'est que vous avez ce même sentiment
dire que clotilde a vécu une histoire
d'amour très forte avec quelqu'un mais
on s'est rencontrés indigne ne disait
pas une scène d'amour entre vous me
faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas désempli
c'est ça commence à être chaud là
pourquoi pas bernard est donc tout il a
vécu une histoire d'amour très forte
avec quelqu'un et quand elle s'est rendu
compte qu'il était en train de se
détruire mutuellement
un coaching il s'en séparait vous ne
vous dites quand on aime et qu'on était
mais s'il est plus possible de vivre
ensemble il vaut mieux se dire à dieu
plutôt que c'est détruire mutuellement
c'est un si beau jamais ses côtés
misogyne chez vous casser sa peau c'est
un peu gnangnan
non mais c'est vrai mais grave
non je suis tombé moi à mes services je
suis très sentimental je suis ravi que
son seuil à partir de soi quand on était
au cinéma à côté vous n'êtes pas le
tournoi personne parce que le film dure
1h30 mais je suis tombé dedans alors
c'est vrai vous êtes comme ça vaut aussi
plutôt vous le vécu une histoire d'amour
c'était au bout de l'histoire
et puis à un moment vous êtes dit non on
est en train de se détruire vous avez
arrêté là c'était un homme déjà pas
facile à gérer ça vous êtes vous êtes
agoraphobe c'est vrai ça ouais moi si tu
es agora vous êtes agrafes à bosser je
suis claustrophobe je pense même pas les
pour venir je prends pas l'ascenseur ici
moi ouais d'accord à pau et vous claquez
c'est pas grave
et vous 22 v'là avec le fonds de cales
et autour du trou c'est dommage que vous
soyez pas en duo fob c'est ce que ça en
duo femmes et des gens qui sont rendus
au club en dur en duo fob où ils veulent
quoi être à deux ça n'a cessé les gens
comparent de sa jeep et bien tu peux
nous la refaire c'est dommage que vous
soyez pas rendu au foyer c'est quoi
c'est les gens qui ont perdu s'habiller
bien voir un peu de promo maintenant
harry va falloir apprendre la nsa voilà
tu fais ça comme ça bah maintenant on va
regarder ce qu'on va regarder ce que
font kad et olivier sur a tout fait sur
comédie sur commune et à son bien ce
qu'ils font on va regarder on y va tout
fils est parti il temps de lecture notre
invité alexandre à cet atoll de lancer
le dé pour ce premier cas bolloc'h ses
parties de rouge de mars
tu marques 10 chevaux et tu avances en
case mot revenait olivier je plonge la
tête la première et je mange une
perruque très bien ouais normal tu fait
coup double et tu lances le javelot avec
sandra pauline est née queue de cheval
bien joué
oui queue de cheval la question à
l'atomic avait le muscle dany brillant
mais bon c'est pas évident tu passe par
la case départ et tu prends dix mille
olivier a peu parlé quels sont à franges
et gobelines on peut dire qu'elles sont
à franges et gobelets d'agneau aux bien
jouer tu épouses nicoletta et tu files
en casse boîtes de 15 secondes
ok avec sandra tremblay
[Musique]
guitare à moustache en 3 c'est entre ces
trois saisons tu peux pas tu as un mini
vélo en opposition
tu descends en case claque beignets
qu'est-ce que tu décides j'insulte
l'homme aux pieds bots et je mange du
foin au laser club carte mystère mystère
ils éliront ni karenni pointu et aux
vannes - trop de balles parfait
j'ai assez bien joué je rate mon choix
je laisse mon cousin croix qui c'est les
plus forts
un pardon qui c'est les plus forts
évidemment c'est les verts on a un bon
public et les meilleurs supporters 15
points supplémentaires
mais voilà oui aux oreilles de lapin
avec sandra bas quatre espèces mise 4
espadrilles serra niger à dos ah non
c'est impossible
elle met de la spab lancé yaourt allumée
de l'extérieur de l'aspartame danser il
ya pourtant pas de chez moi je veux dire
kurdes en cure dents et cure dents et
kurdes aux cordons et kaolack sera
capable c'était si serré lundi mais si
kamoulox pourquoi je gagnais tous les
jours la grosse émission sur comédie
c'est grâce à un jeu recherché j'adore
le jean-michel à peu près jamais seul à
peu près et jean-michel j'ai une triste
nouvelle s'était jamais capitaux
explique tôt
alors maintenant on va baisser à lumière
vous bougez pas mal jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va faire avec kad et olivier qui a
quelque chose à vous ça vous surprendra
pas parce que souvent j'ai vu des choses
de ce type dans le grand cabaret une
mission un succès que vous présentez sur
france 2 patrick sébastien
alors on va faire une interview
télépathie donc je vais vous poser des
questions par télépathie et vous allez
répondre et c'est quoi cet effet à la
télévision parce qu'on est tellement
maintenant alors clotilde si c'est pour
nous déconcentrer ça va pas le faire
attention important vraiment que la
branche et après je ferai un petit peu
avec olivier ça marche aussi bien que
les deux interviews télépathie première
question répondent et 31 cm au repos
on va faire fort tu fait qu'on parlait
pas de moi en algérie maintenant dans
l'élevage me déconcentre s'il vous plaît
c'est compliqué deuxième question tu
peux répéter la fin la question
non non je trouve pas que sébastien soit
ringarde d'accord avec toi tu vois
[ __ ] bien à vous maintenant [ __ ] un
accent tu vas voir
ouais ah ouais ouais je peux te faire la
barre est à 200 balles si tu veux et
tant que deux barytons dernière question
linda hardy
bravo pour allumer la lumière calais
olivier l'interview télé fatigues
exceptionnelles
on a le cas est maintenant l'entraîneur
de l'équipe de france de rugby bernard
laporte
[Musique]
l'histoire
salut bernard j'en ai c'est sébastien
est ce que c'était un bon tu aies croisé
on se connaît bien c'est à un mamba 30
clubs mais jamais été mon patron mais
c'était un bon patron il a fait de
belles choses la preuve il a eu beaucoup
de résultats avec le club de brive
mais vous savez comment il a été viré
sébastien attend enfin se marient non
mais elle se marie en septembre moi je
suis pas été viré sévenans mais c'est
mort toute façon tu viens après
l'émission non non
non
et
entre nous
je vous demande de vous arrêter de nous
arrêter là ma faim c'est toi bon alors
vous savez comment il a été comment il a
été viré de virer je dirais non il y
aussi du recul voilà pendant j'ai pris
du recul
j ai simplement élus ont dit président
d'honneur si tu restes au club patrick
si tu restes président de brive on va te
mettre des mauvais arbitres on va de
pénaliser donc il est parti presque 500
et ça arrive ça dans mon rugby ça aussi
la créatine parce que lui il dit qu'il
prenne de la créatine dans le rugby
champagne les vosges évite la créatine
existait dans le rugby en général et
qu'ils l'étaient pas et que vous avez
dit font pas tout seul de l'eau minérale
j'ai dit c'est charlie c'est tous les
jours qu'il devra ne prennent pas de
créatine ah bon en revanche c'est
l'hémisphère sud ils en prennent part
ils ont des engrais ou s'ils en font la
publicité c'est vrai je veux leur
interdisez d'en prendre
oui c'était interdit donc ce n'est moi
qui connaît très très bien le rugby on
se connaît depuis pas mal de temps vers
la porte pour moi c'est pratiquement la
plus belle chose qui soit arrivée au
rugby français en général depuis
quelques années c'est un excellent
entraîneur et avec lui s'il a les mains
libres
je crois qu'on peut sincèrement qu'on
peut être champion du monde
quel bilan vous faites du tournoi des
six nations alors un bilan mitigé je
crois qu'on a beaucoup de regrets parce
que après avoir gagné largement à
cardiff bay je suis donné beaucoup de
blessés nous on n'a jamais pu aligner
j'ai envie de dire notre équipe majeure
donc on a eu des résultats en dents de
scie donc un beau coup de réveil
beaucoup de forfaits il une certaine
lassitude des joueurs
ouais je crois que y'a bon c'est le
sujet actuellement quand les joueurs
français jouent trop donc construisez
vous dites vous je veux être en fait
voudriez qu'ils jouent moins d'une
certaine façon tout à fait je crois
qu'un joueur de me faire sud joue 25
matches par saison un joueur en france
elle joue 40 donc appuyé sur le
mobiliser pendant deux mois ce qui est
très très difficile
vous avez quand même une réputation de
le tueur un peu de mecs dur avec les
équipes non non je vous appelle le
kaiser en général les mecs qu'on appelle
le kaiser c'est pas des mecs sympas
le père de courant la plupart kaiser
comme je sais très logique mais moi
j'aime pas parler de moi et puis sony
qui a dit un jour que j'étais un kaiser
il a certainement des raisons de nous le
dire non je crois pas que je sois je
suis rigoureux parce que bon j'ai des
convictions et je sais où je veux aller
mais je crois que c'est tout entraîneur
français est comme ça c'est le frère de
calais il a pas beaucoup de conviction
et comment la nourriture non il c'est un
perfectionniste mais il est très
chaleureux m'avait aussi les chaleureux
lui il alterne la porte il alterne la
carotte et le bâton c'est à dire elle
est allé très très chaleureux et des
fois ils critiquent ses joueurs peut
être très simple comme ça mais il faut
si on veut relancer
je crois qu'il faut effectivement il ya
un match fade oui et puis bon jour faut
bien faire la part des choses il ya le
terrain puis alors est je crois que dans
le rugby ya une certaine convivialité
qu'il faut pas perdre
après quand on est sur le terrain il
faut que sérieux il faut gagner il faut
s'entraîner avec beaucoup de rigueur
alors vous vous êtes donc entraîneur de
l'équipe de france de rugby faisait
jamais été international c'est bizarre
ça quand même c'est le plus jeune
entraîneur qu'on ait jamais connu avait
jamais été international de rugby jamais
est ce que ça vous en face à vous en
êtes pas de l'autorité par rapport aux
joueurs que vous dirigez non je crois
pas que donneur sont reconnus par le
fait qu'ils aient été ou pas
international non ça n'existe plus
pourquoi vous avez pas été international
vous vous en aviez envie quand même
allégé le 26 mai il y avait meilleur que
moi un homme que je connais je faisais
secondes pour vous étiez pas assez
costaud et jetez pas assez costaud je
n'étais pas assez bon de ses blogs
beauté international
malgré tout pour être entraîneur de gens
vous envoyer au combat contre le monde
entier d'une certaine façon rien parce
que c'est différent on pas être joueur
chacun va jouer en première division
avec beaucoup d'internationaux 2006 même
si j'avais pas le niveau international
j'avais le droit de jouer avec eux quand
même ça vous est venu comment alors
parce que au début bon vous étiez votre
famille d'origine assez modeste
votre père travaille sur les lignes
électriques d'edf et votre mère elle se
lever à 4h pour distribuer les journaux
d'après vous après deux des ménages dont
mais j'ai beaucoup de respect pour sa
wiimote en main le respect pour ça et
ensuite je il ya quelqu'un qui vous a
marqué que si c'est lui qui m'a donné
envie c'est alain pagès c'est lui qui
vous a donné envie de faire ce métier
c'était une profession des questions de
visite qui était de
au lycée rascol à albi et c'est vrai que
de l'avoir côtoyé sam a impulsé j'aime
bien me donner beaucoup d'avis et déjà
que c'était ma passion
quant à son contact mais il s'est passé
quelque chose j'aime bien d'electric
c'est que j'ai voulu un petit peu le
copier il avait de l'énergie beaucoup
d'énergie et quand il me parle et il
avait un charisme énorme est vrai montré
ce que c'était quelqu'un qui avait du
charisme et ses beautés quelqu'un qui se
dévouaient beaucoup il arrivait vite
avec sa r5 plein de ballons je te
faisais jouer tous les manques quelqu'un
de généreux quelqu'un qui le faisait par
coeur par passion je crois que ça
s'oublie pas ouais alors effectivement
vous avez fait gaillac bègles bordeaux
et en 95 et arrive au stade de france
c'est max guazini qui vous à qui vous a
demandé de venir vous êtes monté un
petit peu à contrecoeur parce que
quitter le sud ouest pour une équipe
parisienne du du groupe b ce n'était pas
évident qu'est ce qui vous a séduit
comment es tu arrivé à vous convaincre
de venir vous installer ici
déjà c'est vrai que j'avais pas du tout
envie de venir à paris de plus le club
était le staff français ces sujets
étaient un groupe un groupe mais qui
correspond à la troisième division et je
suis venu une fois puis max est
quelqu'un de très attachant je crois que
moi j'avais d'abord peur de paris c'est
vrai que petit provincial qui monte à
paris elle se vit puis bros on contacte
je crois qu'il m'a fait bien de trois
jours la vie parisienne a examiné au
palace c'est vrai ouais mais tu as loupé
jour j'étais si impressionné non remise
à ce prix vous a appris à fréquenter les
médias vous habiller ouais je crois
qu'après m'a beaucoup apporté mais moi
c'est un mec je crois qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de feeling entre nous est
souvent assez se réussit donc le tilt
c'est vrai surtout si la regarde alors
il a été le secrétaire particulier
dalida max guazini et quand il parle de
vous ils vous compare à dalida
vous savez ça qu'est ce que vous savez
de comparable avec des emballages tiens
j'aimerais bien le savoir mais je n'ai
pas eu la chance de connaître des lilas
il me disait qu'après les apprécier
après ses concerts fait un peu c'est ses
émissions bien souvent un pic et des
coups de colère il me dit et urs el
madhali d'à peine 22 mur après match
faut pas te parler
ah oui c'est ça je sais pas j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de croiser je sais pas j'ai
c'est de vous imaginer ans david à la
cdu
bien alors tous les cas ça a marché
puisque vous avez le bouclier de brennus
en 98 c'était la première fois depuis
enfin pour ce club là en tous les cas
depuis 90 ans depuis 1908 et en 99 la la
coupe de france et là vous êtes parti
pour vous occuper de l'équipe de france
donc vous êtes ça vous a flippé quoi
mais je crois que c'est difficile de
refuser même si c'est vrai que j'ai
quitté le stade français ce sujet avec
beaucoup de beaucoup d'émotion parce que
ce jeu vous êtes parti est rentré chez
vous êtes mieux vivre des chalets vous
dites comme un gosse
ouais non fiché mais le dernier match
avec avec mes joueurs où j'avais
l'occasion de leur parler que le dernier
briefing parce que c'est vrai que
l'entraîneur c'est toujours je vous sais
pas je parle avec ses joueurs de les
motiver et puis le jour où on a perdu un
pouce en irlande et que je savais que
c'était mon dernier un deuxième
puisqu'un nouvel entraîneur allait être
nommé
mais c'est vrai que j'ai craqué quand je
suis rentré détruit je me suis dit je
vais jamais plus jamais je leur
parlerais j'avais l'impression de
quitter une famille quoi mais a
conseillé formidable c'est votre fils
quoi vous dis faut sélectionner franck
combat castaignède je vais te la faire
moi ton équipe
il a 9 ans on va faire disait le dit
mais c'est vrai que pour lui c'est
facile quoi il a vue de sélectionner
mais qu'avec il y fut z
c'est bien ça va pas entre vous là je
vois que ça va pas changer de place tout
il avec changer de place vanessa vous
serez mieux
voilà bah bah j'ai gagné je rigole
autant cette émission rigole temps
sidney file dans ta chambre
la grosse émission prochaine à venir
elle va pas venir bien pichoff je vous
salue allez vous voulez vous coucher un
oui c'est sûr parce que demain une
grosse journée encore voilà à calais et
merci de votre viendra vaut vraiment
bravo j'avais passé commande soit 24 mai
au 7 mai on sera en soit tous cas
ce cas les nantais sont en jaune aussi
quand vous allez faire que c'est qui va
changer le maillot celui ci je pense je
sais pas c'est jaune et vert maintenant
nous je le sens à regarder nos couleurs
avant l'accord come on come on est le
petit poucet ils ont ils seront
peut-être indulgent d'accord on espère
torse nu au dos et me fait beau merci
beaucoup
bravo et le 7 mai
salut
[Applaudissements]
là
je vais pas vous lâche plus là j'ai dit
non non j'ai dit non non pas je te fais
j'aime assez bon cette année
non j'ai juste un petit pew là il reste
une place bible à toute façon et je vais
accueillir la personne qui va venir
l'occupé c'est à mon sens le plus grand
écrivain français du moment c'est michel
houellebecq
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être là bonsoir
tout le monde nous arrivait de vacances
là vous êtes bronzés non non non c'est
sous le maquillage enfin si j'étais en
vacances mais je suis pas brosser
ouais c'est une apparence mais ça va
ouais
oui j'ai des soucis je fais des trucs
nouveaux
donc c'est toujours des soucis on va en
parler vous faites de la chanson
maintenant je sais pas si tout le monde
ici connaît michel houellebecq en tous
les cas c'est un écrivain formidable
d'abord il avait écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelait extension du domaine de la
lutte qui était adapté au cinéma
d'ailleurs par philippe harel
ensuite il a fait les particules
élémentaires qui est un moment
extrêmement important et que je vous
conseille de lire si vous l'avez déjà
fait ça s'est vendu qu à trois cent
mille exemplaires oui à part bon y'a
encore donc quelques millions de gens
qui peuvent l'acheter
ça a été traduit en 25 langues ce qui
prouve que a priori et quelque chose ça
devait être adapté au cinéma par pia
l'asse tu as fait ça n'ont eux
ce être adapté au cinéma mais je sais
pas par qui alors les particules
élémentaires donc voilà on peut
l'acheter vous publiez vous avez publié
en septembre naissance donc
vous dites on parle c'est un recueil de
poésie oui mais vous dit en parlant de
redessan je vais profiter de ma zoom
zoom manga ressent vite je vais profiter
de ma nouvelle notoriété pour est sorti
d essayer de sortir la poésie de son
ghetto bas tout le monde de oui oui des
cons
beaucoup de gens ont essayé ouais
moi j'essaye je suis pas le premier
avouait trouver un système en tous les
cas pour sortir la poésie de son ghetto
oui oui je sais que vous avez un cd ben
oui faut faire de la musique quand même
temps quand on trouve la musique qui va
ça peut pas arriver à chaque fois là
vous avez trouvé d'argent ça va bertrand
burgalat qui signe les musiques et ça va
être votre votre présence au printemps
de bourges va être le 20 avril sans
doute l'événement du printemps bourreau
revoilà ouais ça en fait c'est une
vachement bonne idée de mettre des
poèmes en musique ce qui est plus
délicat c'est l'idée que j'interprète
moi même mais ça c'est parce qu'on n'a
pas trouvé donc si un interprète
quelconque à les connaître
eh ouais vaness les brèves de filles
alors
[Musique]
ça
que tout
cette chanson je peux l'écouter en
boucle non mais j'aime beaucoup mon nez
ça mais mais mais je sais pas si j'ai
écrit des trucs bien pour pour les
filles quoi pour écouter un petit bout
de playa blanca gironde
[Musique]
incroyable mais vrai c'est michel
houellebecq nous soeur des particules
élémentaires qui chante comme quoi tout
est possible tout est possible nous a
fait pas tout est possible oui mais
j'aimerais dire aux autres muraille bien
coûter deux millions aussi la donne ils
y ont eu lieu
moi j'aime beaucoup si vous voulez voir
houellebecq sur scène
donc il ya le 20 avril le printemps de
bourges
c'est l'événement enfin je vous fait une
tournée oui ça sera peut-être mieux
parce que là ce n'est pas encore tout à
fait au point
enfin on va essayer que ce soit bien
ouais c'est plus sûr on met fin mels et
3 mai à paris aux folies pigalle à lyon
transbordeur qui a prouvé toute une vie
une tournée l'hommage angoulême toulouse
bordeaux rennes vous faites tout une
tournée monaco voilà ben oui le ca
devrait
m tout s y apporter ta [ __ ] qu'est ce
que vous arrivez dans la littérature on
vous souhaite le même succès dans le
disque parce que votre bouquin elle
sorti comme ça d'un seul coup ça a été
je me souviens la rentrée 81,18 les
particules élémentaires c'était le livre
ça l'est toujours d'ailleurs on en parle
toujours au moins une fois par semaine
ah ouais ouais une fois par semaine
temps vous suffit pas si si c'est énorme
ouais avec le recul michel houellebecq
comment vous réagissez aujourd'hui
comment vous considérez les polémiques
qui ont suivi la la parution des
particules élémentaires chez flammarion
mais c'est bien qu'ils aient des
polémiques en france son pays
sympathique pour que ça enfin il ya des
polémiques sur des livres il ya une
polémique à vous êtes dedans votive
enfin j'veux pas raconter votre livre
passé c'est non le jour ni l'heure
mais disons qu'il y avait plusieurs
thèmes et notamment une critique des
moeurs libérales et des dérive laxiste
de mai 68 qui est un peu le enfin le
thème si bien qu'à pas de critique du
film la parenthèse enchantée ou où joue
clotilde courau avec vincent elbaz dural
d une paillasse karin viard
voilà l'exemple même michel l'exemple
même alors d'un enfant de 68 là depuis
depuis le début de la soirée n'arrive
pas à tenir on sent bien qu'elle a été
qu elle a été élevée par des parents
baba cool c'est évident mais il a bien
parlé de ça dans son bouquin
les singes là un message depuis que vous
êtes là les sages mais je sais pas les
maisons faut se débrouiller comme vous
pouvez vous avez vous avait choqué
d'abord en disant ça parce que c'est
vrai que c'était la première fois où un
auteur un écrivain disait pas critiquer
68 en dix ans charles manson n'aurait
pas été possible sans 68 donc d'un coup
ça a mis tout le monde devant ses
responsabilités
là je caricature un peu mais c'est ça
l'esprit bat pas sa peine malause way à
peine malheureusement tu es vous disiez
ans dans votre bouquin puis dans les
interviews données par la suite que
finalement 68 c'était surtout pour vous
le triomphe de l'industrie du
divertissement
oui mais je maintiens mes c
façon quand on dit un truc pour la
première fois on peut toujours cette
fois on les ennuis oui le mec qu'a dit
que la terre classiquement il est
désormais possible
et puis alors il y avait aussi dans
votre bouquin ce qui a choqué les gens
c'est que c'est la première fois qu'on
décrivait des scènes érotiques non
satisfaisante parce qu'habituellement
dans l'est dans les films érotiques dans
les livres érotiques tout le monde jouit
tout le monde est content et vous vous
avez vous avez parlé de la sexualité
avec réalise non ouais mais elles sont
pas non satisfaisante non plus sur ses
moyens que c'est mais c'est la réalité
quoi c'est comme dans la vie il ya du
satisfaisant et du pas satisfaisant que
c'est vrai que c'est bon c'est pas de
l'érotisme et de sexualité réel voilà ça
ça a beaucoup choqué aussi parce que
c'est ouais mais des histoires de sexe
est toujours vachement bien tout le
monde est content en fait le truc je
vais vous dire
dites-moi michel le grand secret dans
l'histoire c'est que là le point
culminant des scènes n'est pas la
sexualité dans les scènes sûr que ça
continue après donc la sexualité un
moment qu'intervient au milieu pas une
fin en soi quoi au wef assez parce que
dans tous les films qu'ils soient porno
ou sentimentaux
ça finit toujours par le point le plus
sexuel alors que moi je continue après
fluence est bien moins drôle
on espère que les gens continuent à
parler après et donc la sexualité est
intégré dans dans une narration mais une
réflexion sur les films pornos vous
dites que dans les années 70 les
actrices de films porno était moins
jolie qu'aujourd'hui à quoi c'est dû à
votre avis oh ben ça c'est simple c'est
parce que maintenant que tout le monde
accepte de fines faire des films pornos
si j'obtiens plus de concurrence donc
c'est les plus belles qui ont le alors
que dans les années soixante dix et
c'est celle qui voulait un peu qu'il ait
tourné quoi donc effectivement les films
pornos sont devenus moins réaliste du
coup parce que les filles sont plus
jolis coups est-ce qui a beaucoup choqué
les gens dont il ya eu effectivement
cette critique de 68 il ya eu cette
façon de raconter la sexualité d'une
façon très quotidienne comme ça très
réel est bien aussi toutes les
limitations du corps humain a par
exemple vous dites vous faisait pas dans
le bouquin mais vous dites dans les
interviews moi l'idée d'un seul sexe ne
semble pas mal ça serait bien qu'on ait
des clitoris et des glands un peu
partout sur le corps et ça va jaser les
quatre heures de plaisir
il ya plein d'idées mais c'est plein non
mais vous avez quand même ça aussi c'est
bizarre c'est l'introduction dans les
michel c'est vrai c'est l'introduction
de la science fiction dans le roman mais
ça non mais j'ai beaucoup chez politique
tout ça moi j'ai beaucoup choqué j'ai
beaucoup choqué parce que moi je n'étais
pas contre les mutations génétiques
ouais et donc le tout les trucs
génétique bizarre qu'on fait moi je
trouve que vous n'êtes pas content le
clonage ou non je suis pas content dit
que c'est une tendance inéluctable
clonage et qui finira toute façon le
clonage humain finira par un progrès ou
de roanne - et donc ça finira par
s'imposer comme mode de reproduction je
pense oui
ayez confiance
alors on vous a accusé ce qui est
incroyable c'est que vous accusez de
véhicules et des fantasmes eugéniques
c'est très vilain totalitaire alors que
vous vous placez la compassion au dessus
de toutes les qualités humaines
quelqu'un vraiment compassionnel ou el
bec à 20 ans il a mis un coup de pied un
pigeon et il dit c'est ce que j'ai fait
plus méchant dans ma vie et je m'en veux
encore est sympa ben oui j'ai pas fait
je peux fait pire ils en souffrent
toujours
mais oui ce pauvre pigeon je sais pas
c'était nous avons changé la mairie
payet un bled un geste de postes postes
délinquants j'ai pas pourquoi les bons
c'est vrai que les pigeons temps en
temps il a beaucoup c'est agaçant
appareil un jet pack et quai de la
marine c'est monsieur blanc c'est moi il
ya eu votre livre a fait a fait scandale
et pour la bonne cause je dirais en
revanche il ya eu un scandale si vous
n'aviez pas le prix goncourt qua non
c'était de plus de plus sérieux et de
plus grave en parlant du prix goncourt
que vous n'avez pas eu
vous avez dit mon éditeur en
l'occurrence flammarion n'avait pas de
ligne budgétaire pour acheter les jurés
bah oui mais ça c'est pas un scoop enfin
bon il paraît que c'est un scoop qu'on
écrive indices mais c'est la première
fois qu'un écrivain dit lui entendu des
éditeurs le dire donc j'avais pas
l'impression de dire un truc si choquant
qu ça ouais je croyais que c'était tout
le monde
tout le monde le savait déjà quoi oui
oui enfin ça se passe pas comme ça c'est
à dire qui leur donne leur demande une
préface et au vu de leur pays la préface
5000 francs et leur paye la préface 50
mille francs ça j'ai dit ça un peu
imprudemment mais je pensais que tout le
monde le savait maintenant voyez enfin
tout le monde le savait personne ne
disait alors il ya une chose pour
terminer avec vous à michel houellebecq
qui vous resterait au delà de tout ça
comme le premier qui a dénoncé les
inégalités sexuelles qu'on avait déjà
dénoncé toutes les formes d'inégalités
et vous vous avez été le premier l'a
aussi à dire un peu comme pour le
concours
mais c'est le premier à dire que la
compétition sexuelle et plus sauvage que
la computer que la compétition
capitaliste et qu'en fait il ya aucune
loi dans ce domaine
tous les coups sont permis c'est la loi
du plus fort ça aussi c'est quelque
chose était le premier
à énoncer c'est à dire qu'en fait là la
vraie compétition c'est la compétition
sexuelle et celle là il n'y a pas
d'égalité possible en plus bas nous que
je suis désolé d'avoir énoncé cette
chose des prix montent mais je n'ai rien
à retrancher là oui je sais qu'elles
sont plus tard évidemment il ya des
clubs échangistes ça c'est le communisme
sexuelle ses lois aux fruits enfin faut
déjà de prolongation voilà c'est le club
d'échangistes m'en fasse tuer alors la
compétition en revanche c'est la gueule
la discothèque c'est la compétition et
c'est dur mais faut pas c'est vrai que
l'on est on est samedi vers 1h du matin
il ya probablement des gens qui rentrent
déprimé il sera sur canal en train de
regarder si bien on va alors vous savez
qu'on ne bouge pas par régine gal êtes
au courant j'ai pas envie de coucher
sèche le savons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux faire une interview fin du monde
que vous êtes quelqu'un de spécial
mangue et comme on vient de le voir
jo jo car il était une fin du monde
alors c'est la fin du monde michel oui
les cordeaux c'est la fin du monde si
vous deviez sauver un livre moi je
prendrais la bible ouais parce que bon
c'est pas abouti mais on peut refaire
plein à partir de la bible donc c'est
très générateur quoi y'a plein de
petites histoires on peut saluer a
beaucoup servi pour refaire des livres à
partir de si vous deviez sauver un
animal bichon frisé le bichon frisé
oui vous aimez les bichons frisés oui
c'est magnifique on voit votre grand
mère avait un bichon frisé baisse et
comme c'est un tout petit chien c'est
comme une peluche
c'est toujours un email non ça ça boit
pas beaucoup à blanc pas du tout n'ont
presque pas et ça vous sautent dessus ça
vous laisse en fait c'est hyper gentil
si vous deviez savez une idée une idée
hausse je vais être un peu chiant c'est
peut-être les l'idée de la preuve
mathématique
ouais ça c'est bien ça beaucoup d'esprit
et nous simplifie la question suivante
un disque et on a trop le vôtre non non
non
beto dans le sait mieux ouais un film
peut-être murnau l'aurore oui si vous
aviez sauver un sexe sa spéciale non on
fait dire ça se pose même pas une drogue
ben moi je dirais le tabac ça a l'air de
rien mais c'est bien si vous deviez
sauver un homme politique ce serait qui
ribéry 60e ben je sais pas j'ai rien
contre
j'ai plaisir à monsieur au bo nettement
j'aime bien chevènement mai
désolé un député lui un coup de pied
comme un pigeon non j'aime bien
chevènement chevènement ah ouais ouais
je trouve qu'il est courageux
les jeunes bon dieu qui l'a sauvé une
fois il ya d'écouté pièce aussi mais
écoutez bien on rallume bien maintenant
mes amis nous allons passer à attention
tout le monde se concentre nous allons
passer à la grande épreuve de l'émission
[Musique]
alors j'espère que frag
j'espère que cannes n'a pas eu les
réponses danse et un spécial c'est un
spécial amour amour
bah oui l'art et comme il y avait
sébastien jeudi puis à bled cdh et jean
d'amour quand on s'est dit on va faire
un spécial amour vous êtes prête
il faut reconnaître les morceaux à la
première fête des équipes voulaient
faire des équipes les comics contre les
accords
j'essaie record c'est un jeu c'est un
blindtest connaît des chansons
reconnaître
[Musique]
soit au coeur
e
stationnez linda hardy et vous donner
les réponses cadres et les envoient
leurs pendules et encore huawei
attention en se concentrant coin pour
cas de maintenant deuxième chanson
thiviers
tiens révélations
c'est
et
c'est l'ancien sébastien il a tellement
passé dans ces émissions montagnais
crappy l'adorable ouais faut mettre
l'effort de côté les formes du côté des
formes gagné on a gagné
attention 15 ans ce qu'on semble un
point pour sébastien un point pour cadre
troisième chanson didier
oui
création là
[Musique]
m
j'en ai un grand honneur mais là on va
dire les deux là ouais ouais c'est dur
vous comptez dans le cas des fonds mais
je suis au taquet danse est toutefois
dans le cas d'un point pour sébastien
quatrième chance quand et josée bastien
[Musique]
et axel et je t'aime donc ça fait quand
même
à joe nick et sur le port de
saint-tropez avec son fils et son fils
il fait rien papa un bateau les johnny
financer un yacht à campsas écrit tu as
raison c'est un bateau oui mais c'est
sébastien qui a trouvé aussi manqué
c'est l'équipe c'est le téléspectateur
qui me demandent téléspectateurs que
chez lui que ça bien sûr son canapé avec
son pétard bien chers amis
téléspectateurs si sébastien qui a
trouvé la chanson écrite par jean renard
ah oui bien que cinquième chanson
[Musique]
je sais
alors là je sais pas comment il a deux
points sébastien quand je suis devant ma
télé ça m'énerve quand je te regarde et
où je trouve tout comme l'épisode michel
bastien cinq doigts
c'est un jeu ça tu sais pourquoi quand
je fais les imitations j'ai travaillé
vachement soit chansons d un troll
attention chanson numéro 7
[Musique]
oh
vanessa le moule
m
[Musique]
dauvin nsa 2 - bravo l koné noirs
d'amérique je suis chanteur d'opéra à
points dont vanessa demain que je
félicite bravo chanson numéro i didier
l'allemagne encore
[Musique]
vient alors maintenant je vais vous
faire le super banco il ya deux chansons
super banco dur donc celui qui les
trouvent pas le gagnant d'accord c'est
le superbe ans a wire c'est pas du jeu
très très dur c'est pas de chanson
suivante
ce diamant super journée
révélation du quai s'est rappelé michel
[Musique]
je crois que tu
m
c'est tout
d'être aussi belle
non stop c'est jacques duval ah oui à
midi aux amis de jean faure qui a créé
beaucoup de chansons pour l'agent plus
amplement sept jours sébastien dernière
chanson suivante
[Applaudissements]
mais
à
[Musique]
à 12h à 17h bong a piqué au vif 'les ya
des week-ends et blanc il faut lui faire
plaisir il n'a pas de cheveux [ __ ]
soyez gentil avec lui ces quatre cas
gagné bravo
moi c'est vanessa enfin selon lui promis
on l'avait dit si tu gagnes tu embrasses
la halle et je trouve pas les ors
allez allez allez m'est venue à l'est
le second allait bien on peut rallumer
ouais ouais bien merci c'était donc tout
le monde en parle donc patrick sébastien
thème le 26 avril en salle peut-il de
courant dans la parenthèse enchantée le
26 avril et d'en rire ma la douce à
chaillot mis en scène par sam arrive le
lendemain le 27
michel houellebecq présence humaine chez
tricatel vanessa demouy bientôt le
marquis et bernard bled
le feuilleton de la mairie de barr et
voilà c'était tout le monde en parle
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
non
là
ah mais non
[Musique]
no
jamais
non
[Musique]
puis baby one
j'écoute
le scra
etc
là
moi
non
nous
tél
m
[Musique]